I could talk for hours about every single episode of how I met your mother.
我可以谈论几个小时关于我如何遇见你母亲的每一件事。
And we do!
我们做到了！
But when it comes to my own health, I used to be pretty clueless.
但当谈到我自己的健康时，我却一无所知。
I'd shrug off low energy, or a fitness plateau is just stress, basically guessing about what my body actually needed.
我会摆脱低能量，或者健身平台只是压力，基本上猜测我的身体实际需要什么。
But you shouldn't guess when it comes to your health.
但当涉及到您的健康时，您不应该猜测。
Instead, you should get the real data that supports your wellness with lab core on-demand health testing.
相反，您应该通过实验室核心按需健康测试来获取支持您健康的真实数据。
On the website, you can choose from a suite of more than a hundred health tests, including micronutrient allergy, testosterone, fitness, sexual wellness, and more, all available to purchase without a doctor's appointment.
在该网站上，您可以从一百多种健康测试中进行选择，包括微量营养素过敏、睾酮、健身、性健康等，所有这些都可以在无需医生预约的情况下购买。
Just purchase a test online, then visit a local lab core location to have your sample collected.
只需在线购买测试，然后访问当地实验室核心地点即可收集样本。
It's so simple.
就是这么简单。
Within days, you'll have accurate results that are easy to understand from a lab doctor's trust.
几天之内，您将获得实验室医生信任的易于理解的准确结果。
To start your journey, visit ondemand.labcore.com slash mother and use code mother to save up to 15% on select tests.
要开始您的旅程，请访问 ondemand.labcore.comlash mother 并使用 code mother 在精选测试中节省高达 15% 的费用。
That's ondemand.labcore.com slash mother and use code mother.
这就是 ondemand.labcore.com 斜线母亲和使用代码母亲。
Know yourself.
了解你自己。
Snapple would like you to take a break from the sheds.
斯内普尔希望你能离开棚屋休息一下。
Those things you should be doing should be finishing should be thinking about well right now Just uh crack open a snapple and just sit tight for a minute while Craig and I share some Snapple real facts with you Not unlike mr.
那些你应该做的事情应该完成，现在应该好好考虑一下，呃，打开一个 snapple，坐一会儿，然后克雷格和我与你分享一些 Snapple 的真实事实，就像 Mr.
Mosby's fun facts mr.
莫斯比先生的有趣事实
Ted Mosby would have a lot of his fun facts We would love these and some of these are even an architecture related So give us our first fact What do you guys, these all feel like things Ted or at least like a future like dad Ted would say All right, here is a snapple real facts 253 the first TV remote control introduced in 1950 was called lazy bones.
泰德·莫斯比 (Ted Mosby) 会有很多有趣的事实 我们会喜欢这些，其中一些甚至与架构相关 所以给我们第一个事实 你们觉得怎么样，这些都感觉像泰德或至少像爸爸泰德会说的未来 好吧，这是一个快照的真实事实 253 1950 年推出的第一个电视遥控器被称为“懒骨头”。
I didn't know that I mean, I mean either real fact 1,517 in New York It is illegal to sell a haunted house without telling the buyer That's actually amazing and that feels like the very that feels like very martial actually These are weirdly resonant.
我不知道我的意思是，我的意思是真实的事实 1,517 在纽约 在不告诉买家的情况下出售鬼屋是违法的 这实际上是令人惊奇的，而且感觉就像是非常军事化的感觉 这些确实产生了奇怪的共鸣。
Okay, fact, that is amazing, and I want to know more, but we don't have time for it in the Snapple Chat.
好吧，事实上，这太棒了，我想了解更多，但我们在 Snapple Chat 中没有时间。
Real facts, 1978.
真实的事实，1978 年。
1,978, I'm going to think, has nothing to do with the year 1978.
我想，1,978 与 1978 年无关。
More than 40 buildings in New York have their own zip codes.
纽约有 40 多座建筑物都有自己的邮政编码。
That is totally a Ted Mosby fund.
这完全是泰德·莫斯比基金。
He would actually know that.
他实际上会知道这一点。
He told every girlfriend that Snapple real fact, 1,667 lovebirds are actual birds.
他告诉每一位女友，Snapple 的事实是，1,667 只爱情鸟是真正的鸟。
And we bring you back to love.
我们让你重拾爱。
It's all full circle.
这都是完整的循环。
It's all very him yummy.
这一切都非常美味。
All right, that's your break.
好吧，这是你的休息时间。
Quick fun and just a little unexpected.
快速有趣，只是有点出乎意料。
Next time you hit pause and make it count with Snapple on your next break.
下次您按下暂停键时，请在下一次休息时使用 Snapple 进行计数。
Hi, I'm Aaron from Orlando.
嗨，我是来自奥兰多的亚伦。
Hi, I'm Stacey from Albuquerque, New Mexico.
大家好，我是来自新墨西哥州阿尔伯克基的史黛西。
Hi, I'm Mimi.
嗨，我是咪咪。
I'm in Los Angeles, but for college, I was in the UK.
我在洛杉矶，但上大学时我在英国。
What how I met your mother means to me is that grief is temporary.
我如何认识你母亲对我来说意味着悲伤是暂时的。
It means for me that happiness and humor are both found in the midst of great tragedy.
对我来说，这意味着在巨大的悲剧中可以找到快乐和幽默。
I saw as things happening in my life happened on screen in real time.
我看到我生活中发生的事情实时发生在屏幕上。
Sometimes we've been on the same day, which was a little fear, but good job.
有时我们会在同一天，这有点害怕，但做得很好。
The writers in the cast allowed those characters to feel all of those heart breaks without the need for an additional laugh.
演员阵容中的编剧让这些角色感受到所有这些心碎，而不需要额外的笑声。
But unfortunately, the episodes didn't air on UK TV at the same time that they aired on US TV.
但不幸的是，这些剧集没有在美国电视上同时在英国电视上播出。
So yes, I was pirating these episodes like rip streaming video length that frequently was reversed.
所以是的，我盗版了这些剧集，比如翻录流媒体视频长度，这些长度经常被颠倒。
So sometimes in my mind, the entrance to the apartment is on the other side of the screen.
所以有时在我的脑海里，公寓的入口就在屏幕的另一边。
I was reminded that things don't always go as planned, but they happen the way they're supposed to.
有人提醒我，事情并不总是按计划进行，但它们会按照预期的方式发生。
And there's always going to be people around to make sure you're okay.
而且周围总会有人确保您一切安好。
I'm alone, I'll be soon.
我一个人，很快我就会了。
In New York City, when I see you, please permit me to tell you everything.
在纽约，当我见到你时，请允许我告诉你一切。
In New York City.
在纽约市。
Hello and welcome to another episode of how we made your mother.
大家好，欢迎收看我们如何塑造你母亲的另一集。
I am Josh Radner.
我是乔什·拉德纳。
I am here with Craig Thomas.
我和克雷格·托马斯在一起。
Hello, everybody.
大家好。
Hello, Craig.
你好，克雷格。
Also, Alex, Lev, our producer and savior and Mr. Fix it all.
还有亚历克斯、列夫、我们的制作人和救世主以及修复一切先生。
And it's only our second episode.
这只是我们的第二集。
But we are already on a very special episode of how we made your mother.
但我们已经在讲述我们如何造就你母亲的非常特别的一集了。
It's very special because we have Carter bays with us.
这很特别，因为我们有卡特海湾。
No, I'm sorry.
不，对不起。
Hi guys.
嗨，大家好。
How are you?
你好吗？
We're really good.
我们真的很好。
Carter bays.
卡特湾。
Well, tell us why you're here Carter.
好吧，告诉我们你为什么来这里，卡特。
What hand did you have in the how I met your mother verse?
在《我如何遇见你母亲》这首诗中，你扮演了什么角色？
I'm pretty, I was there for for a good deal of it.
我很漂亮，我在那里度过了很多时光。
I'm gonna get a lot of props.
我会得到很多道具。
I remember.
我记得。
Yeah, it's my props.
是的，这是我的道具。
Yeah, I was a I'm the card and crag, I'm the carder of card and crag.
是的，我是一个我是卡片和峭壁的人，我是卡片和峭壁的卡片者。
I wish I'd pretended I didn't know Carter was the guest so we could have done the smart less thing.
我希望我假装不知道卡特是客人，这样我们就可以做一些不那么聪明的事情。
Oh my God, it's Carter.
天哪，这是卡特。
So welcome, Carter.
欢迎，卡特。
We're so happy you're here.
我们很高兴你在这里。
It's good to be here.
很高兴来到这里。
Yeah.
是的。
So I love this story.
所以我喜欢这个故事。
This is kind of an iconic origin story for me that you guys have told me, but I want you to tell our audience.
这对我来说是一个标志性的起源故事，是你们告诉我的，但我希望你们告诉我们的观众。
So Matt, you brought him three ideas, five ideas, how many ideas did you bring Matt?
那么马特，你给他带来了三个想法，五个想法，你给马特带来了多少想法？
Editor's note.
编者注。
Josh is talking about Matt Rice, who is Craig and Carter's TV agent.
乔什正在谈论马特·赖斯，他是克雷格和卡特的电视经纪人。
How many ideas did you bring Matt?
你给马特带来了多少想法？
Probably a lot.
可能很多。
Probably more.
可能更多。
Probably ten.
大概十个。
I mean, just throwing out ideas and throwing out titles and areas, and we said it's kind of like one line pitches, or just like very bearable ideas.
我的意思是，只是扔掉想法，扔掉标题和区域，我们说这有点像一行推销，或者只是像非常可以忍受的想法。
Kind of like log ones for like areas of what it could be.
有点像类似区域的日志。
There was like, one of them was like a David Spade vehicle, I think Jason David Spade.
就像，其中一个就像大卫·斯佩德的车，我想是杰森·大卫·斯佩德。
I remember a document.
我记得有一个文件。
I think there was like four things.
我认为大概有四件事。
Like we had a, it was it, was it, was it King's Road Cafe or was it Toast?
就像我们有一个，是它，是它，是国王路咖啡馆还是吐司？
It was one of these two places.
这是这两个地方之一。
King's Road Cafe, I think.
我想是国王路咖啡馆。
I mean, I mean, Toast.
我是说，我是说，吐司。
I was getting wrong, but we had a meeting with Matt and over breakfast and we were like to present our four ideas and I think the first one we read was how I met your mother and he was like, that's it, that's the one.
我错了，但我们与马特会面并吃早餐，我们想提出我们的四个想法，我想我们读到的第一个想法是我如何遇见你母亲的，他说，就是这样，就是这样。
You can read me the other ones but that's the one.
你可以给我读其他的，但只有这一个。
And so it was kind of like a tip.
这有点像小费。
Do you remember what the kind of like log line of it was?
你还记得它是什么样的日志行吗？
I think in light, the sort of storytelling perspective built into the title.
我认为，标题中内置的那种讲故事的视角。
And then when we started talking about how personal it would be to us, that it would be sort of like the couple that's a little bit like me and my wife and the single guy that's a little bit like Carter at the time, I think he was just like, that's where your heart is.
然后，当我们开始谈论这对我们来说是多么个人化时，这有点像一对有点像我和我妻子的夫妇，以及当时有点像卡特的单身汉，我想他就像，那就是你的心所在。
Your heart isn't, you know how to write that.
你的心不在，你知道怎么写。
But he had, his reaction was more like visceral and immediate.
但他做到了，他的反应更像是本能的、直接的。
It was almost a little more magical than that.
它几乎比那更神奇一点。
The more we talked about it, the more it was like that also was right.
越聊越觉得这也是对的。
What you know, do that one.
你所知道的，就去做吧。
You don't know the worlds of these other things you're pitching right your world.
你不知道你正在向你的世界推销的其他事物的世界。
And we went from New York, we missed New York.
我们从纽约出发，我们想念纽约。
That was part of the flavor of the show, our nostalgia for having left what was our home for a bunch of years.
这是这部剧的特色之一，是我们对离开家乡多年的怀念。
And he's like, you can do that.
他说，你可以做到。
That's going to bring out the heart.
这样才能把心掏出来。
Right, Carter?
对吧，卡特？
And he's a softie.
而且他是个软蛋。
And he's got a real emotional core that Matt Rice.
他和马特·赖斯一样拥有真正的情感核心。
And I think, you know, he's kind of our age is a little bit older, but I think he wanted to see what we could do just writing about, because Oliver Bean was about a 12-year-old kid living in the 1960s and then we're growing American dad.
我想，你知道，他的年龄比我们大一点，但我想他想看看我们能写些什么，因为《奥利弗·比恩》讲述的是一个生活在 1960 年代的 12 岁孩子，然后我们正在成长为美国爸爸。
We were writing all these shows that were like sort of not, not our, we worked on the method in red sitcom.
我们正在写的所有这些节目都有点不是，不是我们的，我们在红色情景喜剧中采用了方法。
So I mean, method man is not, we aren't the natural choices to have the voice of method man.
所以我的意思是，方法人不是，我们不是拥有方法人声音的自然选择。
But yeah, I think he just saw that it was like, oh, this is going to be cracking harder, really writing their own lives and talking about stuff that's going on with them.
但是，是的，我想他只是看到了，哦，这会更加困难，真正写下他们自己的生活并谈论他们正在发生的事情。
And, and that's, that's It's exciting, there's a vulnerability to it that I think was, that appealed to us too.
这很令人兴奋，我认为它有一个弱点，这也吸引了我们。
And I think, and to Matt's credit also, the second thing we pitched was a show that we had no business writing that we ended up selling to Fox.
我认为，也值得马特赞扬的是，我们推销的第二件事是一部我们没有业务编写的节目，最终卖给了福克斯。
And I think Matt always knew he was like, you know, you can sell this one, but how about your mother's gonna be the one that ends up going and low and bold.
我想马特一直都知道他会说，你知道，你可以卖掉这个，但是你的母亲会成为那个最终变得低调而大胆的人怎么样？
Thank God.
感谢上帝。
And boy do you realize that when you sit down to write them, you sit down to write one and you have a bajillion ideas the other one, you're like, I don't know how to get to page 10 on this one.
天哪，你是否意识到，当你坐下来写它们时，你坐下来写一篇，你对另一篇有无数的想法，你会想，我不知道如何读到这一篇的第 10 页。
There's not going to be nine seasons of this.
这个不会有九季。
So did you have to, I mean, I know you're getting paid by 20th Century Fox in kind of like a holding deal.
那么你是否必须这样做，我的意思是，我知道 20 世纪福克斯公司正在向你支付类似于控股交易的报酬。
You can't write for anyone else.
你不能为别人写作。
But did he just say go write this pilot, go write how I met your mother?
但他只是说去写这个试播集，去写我是如何认识你母亲的吗？
We pitched it verbally.
我们口头上提出了这个建议。
We didn't write it.
不是我们写的。
We pitched.
我们投了球。
We pitched both verbally and you go around town, you go to ABC at the, you know, at the time there was no streamers.
我们都是口头推销的，然后你去城里转转，你去美国广播公司 (ABC)，你知道，当时没有彩带。
Again, old, see a four mentioned incredibly old people.
再次，老了，看到四位提到的老得不得了的人。
And you drive in person, no zoom meetings, you drive to NBC, you drive to Fox, you drive to CBS, and you pitch them these ideas.
你亲自开车，没有变焦会议，你开车去 NBC，你开车去福克斯，你开车去哥伦比亚广播公司，然后你向他们推销这些想法。
And we did, we did the rounds for both of those ideas.
我们确实这么做了，我们对这两个想法进行了多次讨论。
So we pitched all the same people, both of those ideas.
所以我们向同一个人推销了这两种想法。
One of them we sold to Fox, which was like the parent company of our deal.
我们将其中一台卖给了福克斯，它就像我们交易的母公司。
They were in the vertical integration over the deal.
他们正在通过这笔交易进行垂直整合。
They didn't get how much, they didn't want how much from other, we pitched it.
他们没有得到多少，也不想从别人那里得到多少，是我们推销的。
How much from other got a bunch of passes?
从其他人那里得到一堆通行证多少钱？
We didn't, you know, landed at CBS, we thought it was a landed NBC, but that didn't work out.
你知道，我们没有登陆哥伦比亚广播公司，我们以为它是登陆全国广播公司，但那没有成功。
And CBS really wanted it.
哥伦比亚广播公司真的很想要它。
They really, it was just the moment that they were looking for a younger show.
他们真的，这正是他们寻找更年轻的节目的时刻。
I don't know if people, I mean, I guess maybe CBS is still like this, but like at the time, especially it was like such a, it was family sitcoms, it was King of Queens, everybody loves Raymond.
我不知道人们是否，我的意思是，我想也许哥伦比亚广播公司仍然是这样，但就像当时一样，尤其是这样，它是家庭情景喜剧，它是皇后之王，每个人都喜欢雷蒙德。
It was so not shows.
原来如此，没有表现出来。
It had the oldest demo, right?
它有最古老的演示，对吧？
Like it didn't have the oldest audience of a major that was like Letterman used to do jokes all the time about like the old people watching, you know, it's like Matt Locke and his show and like that's like, that's CBS.
就像它没有一个专业中最年长的观众一样，就像莱特曼过去一直开玩笑的那样，就像老年人在观看一样，你知道，就像马特·洛克和他的节目一样，那就是哥伦比亚广播公司。
And 60 minutes, you know.
60 分钟，你知道。
You know, so when you, when you pitch the show and CBS buys it, did you have the names Ted Marshall, Lily, Barney, Robin, and those character, they were fully formed at that point?
你知道，所以当你推销这部剧并被哥伦比亚广播公司买下时，你有泰德·马歇尔、莉莉、巴尼、罗宾和那些角色的名字吗？他们在那时就已经完全成型了？
We went in with like a fully formed pitch sheet.
我们带着一份完整的宣传单进来了。
Yeah, we had, I mean, at each character, and like you write up a little description of each character, maybe eight or 10 episode ideas, just in the shape of how the storytelling work, when you, you pitch them sort of like 15 or 20 minutes of like through this pitch document, you're going to give them a flavor of what it will be.
是的，我的意思是，我们对每个角色都写了一些描述，也许是八到十集的想法，就像讲故事的方式一样，当你通过这份推介文件向他们推销大约 15 或 20 分钟时，你会给他们一个大概的感觉。
And by far, the best response in the room was CBS.
到目前为止，房间里反应最好的是哥伦比亚广播公司(CBS)。
These wonderful women of CBS, who got the emotion and the heart behind you, 20 trillion, Julie Purnworth, Edie Mendoza, and they got what this was.
哥伦比亚广播公司（CBS）的这些出色的女性，朱莉·珀恩沃斯（Julie Purnworth），伊迪·门多萨（Edie Mendoza），20万亿美元，她们得到了情感和心灵的支持，她们得到了这是什么。
And they had just been in a meeting with their higher ups there, where the directive was, we want a younger, basically we want it from we want friends, which we did not want to a come and just give them a friend's clone, but it definitely helped us that you see, yes.
他们刚刚在那里与他们的上级开会，指示是，我们想要一个年轻的，基本上我们想要我们想要的朋友，我们不想来，只是给他们一个朋友的克隆，但这确实对我们有帮助，你看，是的。
Wanted a friend.
想要一个朋友。
Yeah.
是的。
It was, I believe it was like really, it was like hauntingly good timing.
我相信这真的是一个令人难以忘怀的好时机。
Like, it was, it was like that morning they had had a meeting and, and it was like, I think the way I heard it phrase was, we're getting in the under 35 game was how they said it.
就好像那天早上他们开了个会，我想我听到这句话的方式是，我们要参加 35 岁以下比赛，他们就是这么说的。
Like, we need to go, you development department, go find us a show for people under 35.
就像，我们需要去，你们的开发部门，给我们找一个适合 35 岁以下人群的节目。
Guys, we want to get the under 100 years old demo.
伙计们，我们想要获得 100 年前的演示版。
We have the rest of it.
剩下的我们都有了。
that you guys were ready with the work.
你们已经准备好工作了。
And then that was a stroke of luck and timing that was, it's a good task for me for you guys.
这对我来说是一个好任务，对你们来说也是一个好任务。
We had to be in the place that really wanted us.
我们必须去真正需要我们的地方。
And like if we had ended up at NBC, like they had three other hammocker mothers loaded in the chamber.
就像我们最终来到了 NBC，就像他们在房间里装了另外三个吊床妈妈一样。
Like we might have been still on.
就像我们可能还在继续一样。
It was like it.
就是这样。
Yeah, friends had just finished.
是的，朋友们刚刚结束。
Friends had just finished.
朋友们刚刚结束。
And I think we would have been so, as much as we dreaded those comparisons to friends, imagine if we had been like the year friends ended, like, and here's this other one, It somehow wouldn't have worked, but in the moment we should say we did not expect to be at CBS and we were worried with the shows too young, it's not going to work there and look, it went nine seasons and people believed in it that worked there and supported it.
我想我们也会如此，尽管我们害怕与朋友们进行比较，想象一下，如果我们像《朋友们》结束的那一年一样，这是另一部，它不知何故不会起作用，但目前我们应该说我们没想到会在哥伦比亚广播公司，我们担心节目太年轻，它在那里不会起作用，看起来，它走了九季，人们相信它在那里工作并支持它。
So it was, it was an amazing bit of luck.
原来如此，真是太幸运了。
And I wrote you this little day to send you a new York City.
今天我写信给你，是想寄给你一个纽约市的情况。
We'll be right back.
我们马上回来。
Alec, you know what happened to me when I found a good therapist?
亚历克，你知道当我找到一位好的治疗师后我发生了什么吗？
happened to you and you found a good therapist.
发生在你身上并且你找到了一位好的治疗师。
I married her.
我娶了她。
Oh!
哦！
My wife Jordana is a therapist, a wonderful therapist, but today we're talking about RULA, which I believe Alec, you have used and can tell us a little more about.
我的妻子 Jordana 是一位治疗师，一位出色的治疗师，但今天我们谈论的是 RULA，我相信 Alec 您已经使用过它，并且可以告诉我们更多相关信息。
I can and I would like to announce first that I did not marry a single one of the therapists that I have used.
我可以而且我想首先宣布，我没有与我所使用的治疗师中的任何一位结婚。
It's good to say that right up front.
最好提前说清楚。
Disclaimer.
免责声明。
Yes, no rule is it's it's fantastic.
是的，没有规则，它太棒了。
It's a it's a way of finding an online therapist and I have used them for years.
这是寻找在线治疗师的一种方式，我已经使用它们很多年了。
It's basically built the way you would want a kind of website like this to be built.
它基本上是按照您想要的类似网站的方式构建的。
You go on and you get to tell a little bit about what what you're looking for and you get a list of therapists and they could be anywhere because this is entirely online.
你继续下去，你可以告诉你一些你在寻找什么，你会得到一份治疗师名单，他们可能在任何地方，因为这完全是在线的。
So you have a very large list and they'll tell you about themselves.
所以你有一个非常大的名单，他们会告诉你他们自己。
They have great bios of what brought them to this work, what interests them, what kind of work they've done in the past, what their techniques are, and you get to get a sense of who they are, which is completely different from we just walk into a therapist's office, you're just meeting this person for the first time, and what's really great about it is you can change, and you could change because the fit isn't quite right, or just actually just recently I changed because it had been a long time with one therapist, I just sort of had a sense that it was time to change, and really makes it so easy, you just go, you have your list of therapists, and you can just choose whoever you feel is the right fit for you.
他们有很好的个人简介，包括他们从事这项工作的原因、他们的兴趣、他们过去做过什么样的工作、他们的技术是什么，你可以了解他们是谁，这与我们走进治疗师的办公室完全不同，你只是第一次见到这个人，真正伟大的是你可以改变，你可以改变，因为不合适，或者实际上只是最近我改变了，因为与一个治疗师相处了很长时间。治疗师，我只是觉得是时候改变了，而且真的很容易，你只要走，你就有治疗师的名单，你可以选择任何你认为最适合你的人。
It almost sounds like Rula, and I hope they're okay with me saying this.
这听起来几乎像鲁拉，我希望他们同意我这么说。
It's like a Somalia for therapists.
这就像治疗师的索马里。
It is.
这是。
It's exactly what it is.
就是这样。
You've got to start what you're looking for and they say, I have a lovely, I have a lovely person in Denver, Colorado for you.
你必须开始寻找你正在寻找的东西，他们说，我在科罗拉多州丹佛市有一个可爱的人在找你。
That's right.
这是正确的。
And they give you just a little bit and you just take a little sip for at first.
他们只给你一点点，你一开始只喝一小口。
You just have your one appointment, see if it fits and if not, you send it back and you get that next bottle.
您只需进行一次预约，看看它是否合适，如果不合适，您将其寄回并获得下一瓶。
And I can attest as Alex long-time friend.
作为亚历克斯的老朋友，我可以作证。
He used to be a mess, and now he's doing great.
以前他一团糟，现在他过得很好。
You knew me in the pre-Rula days, those were dark days.
你在鲁拉之前的日子里认识我，那是黑暗的日子。
Yeah, I don't wish you would pre-rule on anyone.
是的，我不希望你对任何人做出预先裁决。
But they've done great work with you.
但他们和你一起做了很棒的工作。
You're a shining example of what can happen.
你是可能发生的事情的光辉榜样。
Rula helps you find licensed therapists and psychiatrists who truly align with your background in goals rather than just assigning you the first open slot available.
Rula 帮助您找到真正符合您目标背景的有执照的治疗师和精神科医生，而不是仅仅为您分配第一个可用的空缺职位。
Even better, Rula, R-U-L-A, works with over 100 major insurance plans nationwide, bringing the average session copay to just $15.
更好的是，Rula（R-U-L-A）与全国 100 多个主要保险计划合作，使平均疗程自付额仅为 15 美元。
They support you from day one, tracking your milestones, and helping you monitor your care along the way to ensure you are actually moving forward.
他们从第一天起就为您提供支持，跟踪您的里程碑，并帮助您全程监控您的护理，以确保您真正取得进展。
Thousands of people are already using RULA to get affordable high quality therapy that's actually covered by insurance.
成千上万的人已经在使用 RULA 来获得负担得起的高质量治疗，而且这些治疗实际上是由保险承保的。
Visit RULA.COM slash your mother to get started.
访问 RULA.COM 砍掉你的母亲即可开始。
That's RULA-R-U-L-A.COM slash your mother.
那是 RULA-R-U-L-A.COM 砍你妈妈。
You deserve mental health care that works with you, not against your budget.
您应该得到适合您的心理健康护理，而不是违反您的预算。
You know, there was a time when I would ignore, or maybe not even notice, when my sheets started slipping off the corners or pilling, or when my pillows weren't quite as supportive as I wanted them to be.
你知道，曾经有一段时间，当我的床单开始从角落滑落或起球，或者当我的枕头没有我想要的那么支撑时，我会忽略，甚至可能没有注意到。
My wife, however, has always noticed this sort of thing.
然而，我的妻子总是注意到这种事情。
But now that we got a baby waking up at various times, uh...
但现在我们有了一个在不同时间醒来的婴儿，呃......
every moment of sleep has become in valuable and i am so delighted that bull and branch sent us uh...
每时每刻的睡眠都变得弥足珍贵，我很高兴公牛和树枝给我们带来了呃......
some of the comfiest sheets that i have ever had the pleasure to sleep upon their organic cotton bedding is designed for deep uninterrupted rest which is what we're getting uh...
我曾有幸睡过一些最舒适的床单，他们的有机棉床上用品专为深度不间断的休息而设计，这就是我们得到的呃......
the sheets are incredibly soft they're breathable and it's a total game changer for our energy levels uh...
床单非常柔软，透气，这完全改变了我们的能量水平呃......
especially with this young Occasionally sleeping baby we have now, this is the kind of comfort we can't afford to compromise anymore.
尤其是对于我们现在这个偶尔睡觉的小婴儿来说，这是我们不能再妥协的舒适感。
Upgrade your sleep with Bowling Branch, get 15% off your first order plus free shipping at BowlingBranch.com slash your mother with code, your mother.
通过 Bowling Branch 升级您的睡眠，首次订单可享受 15% 折扣，并在 BowlingBranch.com 上使用代码砍掉您的母亲，您的母亲。
That's Bowling Branch, B-O-L-L-A-N-D branch dot com slash your mother, code your mother to unlock 15% off exclusions apply.
那是保龄球分店，B-O-L-L-A-N-D 分店 . com 削减你的母亲，编码你的母亲以解锁 15% 的折扣排除适用。
Hey Craig, you know now that I have a child, a baby in the house, you know what I'm finding it hard to do?
嘿克雷格，你现在知道我有一个孩子了，家里有一个婴儿，你知道我觉得做什么很难吗？
What?
什么？
To remember to do?
要记得做什么？
What's that?
那是什么？
Eat food.
吃食物。
Yes, that's one of the basic needs that is no longer the priority.
是的，这是基本需求之一，但不再是优先事项。
I know, and I forget, it's like, oh I forgot to feed Nelson, my dog, and myself.
我知道，但我忘记了，就像，哦，我忘了喂尼尔森、我的狗和我自己。
So how are we going to solve that problem?
那么我们要如何解决这个问题呢？
Well, I just need something, just quick on the go that I won't, no must, no fuss.
好吧，我只是需要一些东西，只是在旅途中快速，我不会，没有必要，不用大惊小怪。
You know, I just need to feed myself and get some energy so I can get back to parenting.
你知道，我只需要养活自己并获得一些能量，这样我就可以回去养育孩子了。
Yes, and so what would solve that problem?
是的，那么什么可以解决这个问题呢？
I'm gonna steer you towards an outcome and the outcome is this product you're about to mention.
我将引导你走向一个结果，而这个结果就是你要提到的这个产品。
Oh, oh, wait, are you talking about the, are you talking about the variant meets little lamb, yeager, snacks, ticks?
哦，哦，等等，你是在谈论，你是在谈论与小羊羔、耶格尔、零食、蜱虫相遇的变种吗？
We agreed, that's what, right before we started talking He said, that's what we're going to talk about.
我们同意，这就是我们要讨论的内容，就在我们开始讨论之前，他说，这就是我们要讨论的内容。
Well, this is what I want to talk about.
嗯，这就是我想讲的。
The great tasting Bavarian meets Lil' Lan Yeager, Snack Sticks.
美味的巴伐利亚风味与 Lil' Lan Yeager 零食棒相遇。
They sent us some of these, and they are delicious, and they solve the central problem of my life, which is I forget to eat.
他们给我们送来了一些，它们很美味，它们解决了我生活中的核心问题，那就是我忘记吃饭。
They're naturally fermented, they're made with real ingredients, slow smoked for bold flavor packed with 9 grams of protein per serving, and have zero sugar and zero carbs.
它们是自然发酵的，采用真正的原料制成，缓慢熏制，味道浓郁，每份含有 9 克蛋白质，并且零糖和零碳水化合物。
Also, I have a 19 year old boy.
另外，我有一个19岁的男孩。
a good moment to get a bunch of this product because he will eat us out of house and home.
这是购买一堆这种产品的好时机，因为他会把我们吃得连家都不剩。
Yeah.
是的。
And he loves this stuff.
他喜欢这个东西。
It's so great.
太棒了。
I'm very grateful we got.
我很感激我们得到了。
We got to sample this.
我们必须对此进行采样。
My son is going to eat it all.
我儿子要把它全部吃掉。
I'm going to have like none of it.
我什么都不会。
But okay.
但好吧。
It's a snack that keeps up with your day, whether you're racing between meetings or feeding babies or 19 year olds.
无论您是在赶会议还是在喂养婴儿或 19 岁的孩子，它都是一款适合您一天的零食。
You're doing school drop off just trying to finish your to-do list.
你正在放学，只是想完成你的待办事项清单。
Take a moment to savor something delicious for you or your children.
花点时间为您或您的孩子品尝美味的食物。
And did we mention they're portable?
我们有没有提到它们是便携式的？
Toss a few in your glove box, your gym bag, the diaper bag, wherever.
在您的手套箱、健身包、尿布包中或任何地方都扔一些。
We have a diaper bag.
我们有一个尿布袋。
I bet you do.
我打赌你会的。
Two or three of those bad boys.
两三个坏男孩。
Pick up a pack today, your local grocer, or stock up at bavarianmeats.com slash podcast.
立即从当地杂货店购买一包，或在 bavarianmeats.com 斜线播客上购买。
Use code mother10mother10 at checkout for 10% off your first order.
结帐时使用代码 mother10mother10，首次订单可享受 10% 折扣。
The variant meat snacks, sticks, great taste, zero sugar.
变种肉类零食，棒，味道好，零糖。
When you guys pitched it to all those places around town, did you have the 40 to 60 scene narrative structure, or was that something you discovered while you were writing?
当你们把它推广到镇上的所有地方时，你们有 40 到 60 个场景的叙事结构吗？或者这是你们在写作时发现的东西？
I think we had, and that's how I met your aunt, Robin, and I know we had that.
我想我们有过这样的经历，我就是这样认识你阿姨罗宾的，我知道我们有过这样的经历。
I don't know if we had like every scene beaten out for sure, but we definitely, I don't think we had like a season arc of any kind, which I think nowadays, you know, like in hindsight, you know, this, this wasn't a place that wanted a season arc.
我不知道我们是否每个场景都被淘汰了，但我们绝对，我不认为我们有任何类型的季节弧，我认为现在，你知道，事后看来，你知道，这，这不是一个想要季节弧的地方。
Again, this is, this is, this is a CBS in 2005, like, like what's the season arc on King of Queens?
再说一遍，这是，这是，这是 2005 年的 CBS，就像《皇后之王》的这一季剧情是什么？
There is no arc.
没有弧线。
It's the same show 22 times in a row.
同一场演出连续演出22次。
We never even found out who the king was.
我们甚至不知道国王是谁。
I never even answered that.
我什至从未回答过这个问题。
That's worth also pointing out to our listeners who are using magical devices to listen to all this.
这也值得向我们使用神奇设备来收听这一切的听众指出。
Like the notion that it's a big deal that how I met your mother really needs to be seen from beginning to end.
就像我如何认识你母亲这件大事确实需要从头到尾地看一样。
You could pop in if you wanted to.
如果你愿意的话可以进来。
But nowadays on Netflix, of course, you're doing that.
但现在在 Netflix 上，你当然可以这样做。
You're just watching it straight in a row, but can you just talk a little bit about that style of sitcom at the time that this was very different.
你只是连续看它，但你能谈谈当时情景喜剧的风格吗？这是非常不同的。
Yeah, it's funny.
是的，这很有趣。
I'm having a fight with my with my daughter right now about this very thing because now it's advanced to like she's somehow got her hands on the TikTok.
我现在正在和我的女儿就这件事吵架，因为现在她已经以某种方式获得了 TikTok。
We've like, we've like, you know, we thought we'd barred up all the windows, but I found its way into the cellar or something.
我们喜欢，我们喜欢，你知道，我们以为我们已经封锁了所有的窗户，但我发现它进入了地窖或其他地方。
And like she's watching like, like, cut downs of scenes on TikTok and like, finding out twists in the series.
就像她正在观看 TikTok 上的场景剪辑之类的，找出该系列中的曲折。
And I'm like, no, we're supposed to sit down and watch this together.
我想，不，我们应该坐下来一起看这个。
like the kid and the kids, it was going to be a whole thing, but yeah, anyway, at the time we were, Craig and I, I think our favorite show on TV at that time was Buffy the Vampire Slayer, which we had both devoured on, it was right at the dawn of the DVD box set, like the season box set.
就像孩子和孩子们一样，这将是一个整体，但是，是的，无论如何，当时我们，克雷格和我，我想我们当时最喜欢的电视节目是《吸血鬼猎人巴菲》，我们都狼吞虎咽地看了它，它正好是 DVD 套装的黎明，就像季套装一样。
And we loved these CVD, because they told individual stories, like each episodes, the one where this happened, the one where that happened, but they're beautifully laid out in this season-long arc that has this big satisfying conclusion at the end of the season.
我们喜欢这些 CVD，因为它们讲述了单独的故事，就像每一集一样，发生过这种情况的那一集，发生过这种情况的那一集，但它们在整个季节的弧线中精美地布置，在季节结束时有一个令人满意的大结局。
And I remember thinking, our goal, when it's like, we're going to make a show, was like, if this show makes it a full season, we're not even going to hope for more than one season, but just to have to make something that there's a DVD box set of.
我记得我当时想，当我们要制作一部剧时，我们的目标是，如果这个剧能制作一整季，我们甚至不会希望超过一季，而只是制作一些有 DVD 盒装的东西。
Oh, yeah.
哦，是的。
I think that was the goal.
我认为这就是目标。
I feel like it was nothing.
我感觉好像没什么。
That was the goal.
这就是目标。
like a novel on our shelf, right?
就像我们书架上的小说一样，对吧？
Carter, we're like, I want that little spine.
卡特，我们说，我想要那个小脊椎。
I want the spine that says, how much I'm under, even if it gets canceled, we always have that one little novel says thing of a technology that's going to disappear in five years is with it.
我想要的书脊说，我承受了多少压力，即使它被取消了，我们总是有一本小小说，说一项将在五年内消失的技术随之而来。
It was like right before or right around the time the whole, I think of my show as a novel became a cliche, but it was like right before it became a cliche.
就好像就在整个时间之前或前后，我认为我的节目作为一部小说成为了陈词滥调，但就像就在它成为陈词滥调之前一样。
We were the first ones to say that bullshit line.
我们是第一个说这句废话的人。
But it was like, yeah, I mean, that was, and you know, CBS, That's when we pitched it, didn't say, like, what happens in episode two, what happens in episode five, which should have clued us in, because, you know, we, you know, we wanted to tell it, you know, we felt like this is the first chapter of a saga.
但这就像，是的，我的意思是，那就是，你知道，哥伦比亚广播公司，当时我们推销它，没有说，第二集发生了什么，第五集发生了什么，这应该给我们提供线索，因为，你知道，我们，你知道，我们想告诉它，你知道，我们觉得这是一个传奇的第一章。
Like, this is, we're going to tell a story, and it, I mean, and maybe this is a discussion for down the road, but it became, there, there was some, there were some big disagreements about, like, what kind of show we were making, because they wanted to show that anyone who hasn't seen the show can just jump right in on, you know, on any given Monday in February and just drop right in and be like, okay, I got it.
就像，这是，我们要讲一个故事，我的意思是，也许这是一个未来的讨论，但后来，关于我们正在制作什么样的节目，存在一些很大的分歧，因为他们想表明，任何没有看过这个节目的人都可以直接加入，你知道，在二月的任何一个周一，然后直接加入，然后说，好吧，我明白了。
I see what's going on and I can watch this.
我知道发生了什么，我可以观看。
Whereas Craig and I, we had our eyes on, you know, the season box set.
而克雷格和我，我们关注的是，你知道的，本季套装。
We had our eyes on like we're making something that people sit down and devote a whole afternoon when they're sick and bad to just like watching season one of How Me Your Mother.
我们专注于制作一些东西，让人们在生病或身体不好时坐下来花一整个下午的时间，就像观看《How Me Your Mother》第一季一样。
But at the beginning, we really looked 15 years old.
但一开始，我们看起来真的只有15岁。
We'd never run a TV show.
我们从来没有经营过电视节目。
We were running these weird 70 scene scripts in 21 minutes and they took a second for them to kind of understand, can this fit into the Monday night lineup?
我们在 21 分钟内运行了这些奇怪的 70 个场景脚本，他们花了一点时间才明白，这可以融入周一晚上的阵容吗？
It really strikes me that it's so hard to create something new in Hollywood in that structure that moves so glacial.
让我印象深刻的是，在好莱坞这样一个冰冷的结构中创造出新的东西是非常困难的。
You know, like, I think what was so smart about the way you guys conceived of this show is like five friends hanging out had been done and seen before.
你知道，我认为你们构思这个节目的方式是如此聪明，就像五个朋友一起出去玩一样，以前已经做过和看过了。
But you have this other thing of like framed as a flashback the nonlinear structure, this kind of wildly inventive news storytelling.
但你还有另一种类似的东西，它被框架为非线性结构的闪回，这种极具创意的新闻故事讲述方式。
I used to tell people they would say, what's the show like that you're doing?
我曾经告诉人们他们会问，你正在做的节目怎么样？
And I'd say it's like if Pulp Fiction was a sitcom.
我想说，这就像《低俗小说》是一部情景喜剧。
You know, there was something about the way it was a puzzle, right?
你知道，这是一个谜题，对吧？
And sometimes there were episodes that were very puzzle-like of how I met your mother where just like Ted Mosby architect is like a very strange mystery, right?
有时，有些情节非常像我如何遇见你母亲的谜题，就像泰德·莫斯比建筑师一样，就像一个非常奇怪的谜团，对吧？
Until you get what's happening at the end.
直到你明白最后发生了什么。
And it rewards your patience and fidelity to it, which is why I think one, it scared probably the network, but two, I think that's what created some of the fervor and excitement and loyalty to the show among the hardcore fans was they got invested in a different way because they felt like they were growing alongside or with the characters.
它会奖励你的耐心和对它的忠诚，这就是为什么我认为第一，它可能会吓到电视网，但第二，我认为这就是铁杆粉丝对这部剧产生热情、兴奋和忠诚的原因，因为他们以不同的方式进行投资，因为他们觉得自己正在与角色一起成长。
Yeah, I think the audience felt respected and the audience felt like they were sort of our accomplices in this little weird kind of mystery crime.
是的，我认为观众感到受到尊重，观众感觉他们是我们这种奇怪的神秘犯罪的同谋。
We were trying to pull off and they felt invested.
我们试图成功，他们感到投入了。
And it's funny how a lot of the best episodes of how much mother are mini mysteries within this larger mystery.
有趣的是，在这个更大的谜团中，有多少关于母亲多少的最佳剧集都是迷你谜团。
That's another thing that I always kind of love about.
这是我一直喜欢的另一件事。
What works on that show, on Earth.
在那个节目中，在地球上，什么是有效的。
Yeah.
是的。
But like, being able to use that device for puzzle building was always fun.
但是，能够使用该设备来构建拼图总是很有趣。
Like, like, episodes like three days of snow, I don't know if you remember that one, like, yeah, or the burning beekeeper.
就像三天的雪这样的情节，我不知道你是否还记得那个，比如，是的，或者燃烧的养蜂人。
Things that really like, you know, like, Pulp Fiction was absolutely, I mean, I don't think anyone, Rage, who was in the movies, wasn't, didn't catch some, some, uh, uh, uh, flag from that like, just just like, just the, the, the creative energy just, uh, vibrating off of it, like, I feel like it's steeped its way to everyone.
真正喜欢的东西，你知道，像，低俗小说绝对是，我的意思是，我认为电影中的愤怒，没有人，没有抓住一些，一些，呃，呃，呃，旗帜，就像，只是，这个，创造性的能量只是，呃，从它身上振动，就像，我觉得它浸透了每个人的方式。
I remember, uh, when I read episode two, after the show had been picked up.
我记得，呃，当我读到第二集时，在节目被接播后。
I was so delighted that the DNA of what I loved about the pilot was just even more there in the second episode.
我很高兴在第二集中更加体现了我对试播集的热爱。
I was like, oh, it's just going to keep moving like this.
我当时想，哦，它会继续这样移动。
And I was delighted by it.
我对此感到很高兴。
So I do want to ask you guys, CBS says yes.
所以我想问你们，哥伦比亚广播公司说是的。
They're not going to make the pilot.
他们不会做飞行员。
They order a script.
他们订购了一个剧本。
Is that right?
是这样吗？
Yeah.
是的。
They order a script.
他们订购了一个剧本。
You write the pilot script and submit some episode ideas for future episodes, which we are anywhere kind of had and probably mentioned in the pitch, but then you more formally do that along with the script.
你编写试播剧本，并为未来的剧集提交一些剧集创意，这些创意我们在任何地方都有过，并且可能在推介中提到过，但随后你会与剧本一起更正式地这样做。
You spent a whole fall of some prejudiced fall of 2004.
2004年，你在充满偏见的秋天度过了整整一个秋天。
We're writing on American dad, and then at night, right on the weekend, writing...
我们正在写《美国爸爸》，然后在晚上，就在周末，写……
Your mistress was how I really loved her.
你的情妇是我真正爱她的方式。
And this other mistress, Torrid, hot Torrid affair with amateur mother, and a less Torrid affair with the other failed pilot we weren't that into writing.
还有另一个情妇，热辣，与业余母亲的热热恋情，以及与另一位失败的飞行员的不那么热辣的恋情，我们不那么喜欢写。
And far less Torrid, and we sort of did that through the fall of 2004, right?
而且远没有那么炎热，我们在 2004 年秋天就做到了这一点，对吗？
Carter and you submit drafts and you get feedback, And we thought they liked it, but you know they buy like what are they buy 30 scripts 30 pilot scripts And they make 10 of them something like that probably I'm getting the numbers wrong We didn't think we'd ever even be one of those 10 maybe they buy 50 scripts and make 10 and then we were one of those 10 by this 10 Late winter spring was rolling around they say it's like the one of the 10 we shoot.
卡特和你提交草稿，你得到反馈，我们以为他们喜欢它，但你知道他们买什么，他们买了30个剧本，30个试播剧本，他们制作了其中10个类似的东西，可能我把数字弄错了，我们没想到我们会成为这10个剧本中的一员，也许他们买了50个剧本，制作了10个，然后到了这个10年，我们就成为了这10个剧本之一，他们说这就像是10 我们射击。
Yeah, it was it was back in the I'll say the good old days of like when when networks all development was on the same schedule.
是的，那是回到了过去的美好时光，当时网络的所有开发都按相同的时间表进行。
Like it was it was the the everybody every writer in Hollywood who once has a TV show they want to make pitches it like in the summer and early fall and every and the ones that sell them everyone is writing their script and handed in you handed in right before winter break so like you you know go home to wherever you're going home to and just spend the actors waiting for January February and March.
就好像好莱坞的每个作家都曾经有一部电视节目，他们想在夏天和初秋的时候进行宣传，而每个卖这些节目的人都在写剧本，并在寒假前交给你，所以就像你知道的那样，回家去你要去的地方，让演员们等待一月、二月和三月。
Yeah and then January is where they're casting them.
是的，然后一月是他们选角的地方。
Yeah the January is when the phone rings and it's, okay, we're making it.
是的，一月份电话一响，我们就成功了。
Like, they take those 30 scripts that they bought and they say, we're gonna make eight of them.
就像，他们拿了他们买的 30 个剧本，然后说我们要制作其中的 8 个。
And these eight pilots are gonna get shot.
这八名飞行员将会被枪杀。
And I'll tell this story, Craig.
我会讲这个故事，克雷格。
I don't know if you remember this.
我不知道你是否还记得这一点。
Like, Craig and I were at...
就像，克雷格和我在...
I think it was the premiere of American Dad.
我认为这是美国爸爸的首映。
There was a premiere party for American Dad in Las Vegas.
《美国爸爸》在拉斯维加斯举行了首映派对。
And Craig and I were in Las Vegas and had a really fun night out.
克雷格和我在拉斯维加斯度过了一个非常有趣的夜晚。
I mean, it was before the very pineapple incident, very, very pineapple incident, which then became the hangover.
我的意思是，那是在非常非常菠萝事件之前，非常非常菠萝事件，然后就变成了宿醉。
I think it was before the party because before the party, the phone rang, and it was Matt Rice, or maybe David Miner, and it was like, let's get both of them on the phone.
我认为那是在聚会之前，因为在聚会之前，电话响了，是马特·赖斯（Matt Rice）打来的，或者可能是大卫·迈纳（David Miner）打来的，就像，让我们给他们俩打电话。
So like, we knew, like, okay, they want both of us on the phone.
所以，我们知道，好吧，他们希望我们俩都通电话。
This is going to be something.
这将会是一件大事。
And they said it was the head of development saying, like, we're good news.
他们说开发主管说，我们是个好消息。
We loved your script.
我们喜欢你的剧本。
We want to make it.
我们想要成功。
We want to make a pilot.
我们想培养一名飞行员。
So you're making a pilot.
所以你正在培养一名飞行员。
And we hang up, we're like, yeah, we did it.
然后我们挂断电话，我们说，是的，我们做到了。
We go downstairs.
我们下楼。
We like celebrate.
我们喜欢庆祝。
We tell all our friends at American dad, they're like, oh, that's great.
我们告诉美国爸爸的所有朋友，他们都说，哦，那太棒了。
You're making a pilot.
你正在培养一名飞行员。
And like, we have a great night.
就像，我们度过了一个美好的夜晚。
And then like wake up in like one in the afternoon, you know, and just kind of connect.
然后就像下午一点醒来，你知道，然后就有点联系了。
And I don't remember exactly how this story unfolded, but basically like Craig and I are just like, oh, I'm making a pilot.
我不记得这个故事是如何展开的，但基本上就像克雷格和我一样，哦，我正在制作一个飞行员。
This is good.
这很好。
It's good.
很好。
The pool.
游泳池。
They're going to relax.
他们会放松一下。
And like we get a call from somebody.
就像我们接到某人的电话一样。
I don't know.
我不知道。
Maybe it was Matt Rice.
也许是马特·赖斯。
basically like, um, so when is your, how many, uh, casting director meetings have you had so far?
基本上就像，嗯，那么到目前为止，你参加了多少次，呃，选角导演会议？
We're like, what do you mean?
我们就像，你什么意思？
It's like, you, you haven't, well, you have some book, right?
就像，你，你没有，嗯，你有一些书，对吧？
You have some casting director, cause it, cause what you don't know is that when it, when it's pilot season and your, your pilot gets picked up, it becomes this mad scramble super market sweep for the best talent.
你有一些选角导演，因为它，因为你不知道的是，当它，当它是试播季节并且你的，你的试播集被选中时，它就变成了对最优秀人才的疯狂争夺超级市场。
And you have to like rush out there and find like, you have to, you have to book your casting director right away.
你必须冲出去，然后发现，你必须，你必须立即预订你的选角导演。
You have to book your, your director right away.
你必须立即预订你的导演。
you have to book like otherwise they'll get snatched up and you won't get them.
你必须像这样预订，否则他们会被抢走，而你不会得到它们。
And so that became like that like the story of January and February was us like scrambling to like cobbled together this rag tag crew who would like be willing to like take a chance on doodling dogs who expect you with a moment you got the green light for your pilot that you would just immediately start calling customers just like professional so they clearly know.
于是，就像一月和二月的故事一样，我们就像争先恐后地拼凑在一起，这些乌合之众的人愿意在那些期待你的涂鸦狗身上冒险，当你为你的飞行员开绿灯时，你会立即开始像专业人士一样打电话给客户，这样他们就清楚地知道。
I thought that call may have come from CBS actually.
我认为这个电话实际上可能是哥伦比亚广播公司打来的。
Yeah, and we got kind of yelled that they're like what the fuck are you doing in Vegas get a casting director what's happening Like right off right off the bat.
是的，我们有点大喊大叫，他们就像你他妈的在维加斯做什么，找一个选角导演发生了什么，就像马上就发生了一样。
We were just completely in overhead didn't know how to because you make this immediate leap from Writer in a room just coming up with ideas to CEO of a corporation that is being given seven figures to make a pilot I mean this was like just the mothership descending like look it's literally the mothership like it was like Like, nothing like anything that had been on CTOS for the podcast, it's good.
我们完全陷入了开销，不知道该怎么做，因为你立即从一个在房间里提出想法的作家跳跃到一家公司的首席执行官，这家公司被给予七位数的资金来制作飞行员，我的意思是，这就像母舰下降一样，看起来它实际上是母舰，就像播客中的任何东西一样，这很好。
Yeah.
是的。
I just wrote that down.
我刚刚把它写下来。
Interesting.
有趣的。
There you go.
就这样吧。
The mothership descent.
母舰血统。
And you have to suddenly put on this boss hat that you have never worn before, really.
而且你必须突然戴上这顶你以前从未戴过的老板帽，真的。
And that was the code.
这就是代码。
That was the very hungover wake up call.
那是宿醉的警钟。
Get on the ball, guys.
加油吧，伙计们。
Go get it.
去拿吧。
Get back to Los Angeles and meet six casting directors, hire the one you're lucky enough that doesn't get hired by the time they're walking to their car after meeting with you because they just met four other people that morning.
回到洛杉矶，会见六位选角导演，雇用一个你足够幸运的人，但他们在与你会面后走向汽车时尚未被雇用，因为那天早上他们刚刚遇到了另外四个人。
And they're gonna choose, if I'm a casting director, I'm gonna choose anyone but us, Carter.
他们会选择，如果我是选角导演，我会选择除我们之外的任何人，卡特。
Cause we looked 12 years old.
因为我们看起来只有12岁。
We didn't know what we're doing.
我们不知道自己在做什么。
We were hungover from Vegas.
我们宿醉在维加斯。
Like God knows what the casting director's was thinking of us.
天知道选角导演对我们的看法。
We have backpacks on.
我们背着背包。
I think that's true.
我认为这是真的。
But I also just to give us some credit, I feel like we wrote a really good pilot.
但我也只是为了给我们一些荣誉，我觉得我们写了一个非常好的试播集。
And I, and the further I get from the more, and the more pilots I've tried to write my life, and you know, they realize like, it really, there was something special to it.
而我，我离得越远，我试图写下我的生活的飞行员就越多，你知道，他们意识到，真的，它有一些特别的东西。
And it also, like, the great thing about it was, it was this self-sorting thing where there were certainly a lot of people that had that reaction and said no, and we're like, no thanks.
而且，它的伟大之处在于，这是一种自我分类的事情，肯定有很多人有这种反应并说不，我们就像，不，谢谢。
But that left more room for the people who got it.
但这为获得它的人留下了更多空间。
Like, the people like Pam found people, and it took on a magical, this is very woo-woo, but it really did feel like it found people, including Mr. Josh Radner, and my God, it became magic the way I found the right people.
就像，像帕姆这样的人找到了人，它呈现出一种神奇的感觉，这非常令人惊叹，但它确实感觉它找到了人，包括乔什·拉德纳先生，天哪，我找到合适人的方式变得神奇了。
Well, it also feels like something that everyone loves is probably not that special.
嗯，感觉每个人都喜欢的东西可能并没有那么特别。
Like a special thing is going to misdify certain people.
就像一件特殊的事情会误导某些人一样。
You know, yeah.
你知道，是的。
And I think that was amazing.
我认为这太棒了。
And I always think a project itself acts as a kind of glowing orb.
我一直认为项目本身就像一种发光的球体。
It attracts the right people.
它吸引了合适的人。
And I do feel like how I made a mother had a kind of frequency that brought people into its orbit who belonged there.
我确实觉得我如何让母亲拥有一种频率，将属于那里的人们带入其轨道。
Um, yeah, namely who actually is just a huge hero of the show who we all adore, but how did Pam Fryman, our beloved director, get, how did you find your way to her, her to you?
嗯，是的，也就是说，他实际上是我们都崇拜的剧中的大英雄，但是我们敬爱的导演帕姆·弗莱曼（Pam Fryman）是如何得到的，你是如何找到通往她的路的，她是如何找到你的路的？
I mean, that's the other, that's the perfect example and that happened that she could have directed any pilot.
我的意思是，这是另一个，这是一个完美的例子，碰巧她可以指挥任何飞行员。
She was a hot in demand director.
她是一位炙手可热的导演。
She had been directing on two and a half men, which was like the number one comedy at the time, I think.
她一直在执导《两个半男人》，我认为这就像当时排名第一的喜剧。
And again, she, she was probably given 20 job offers that year, right, Carter, she could have done anything, she just read this and connected to it.
再说一次,她,那一年她可能得到了20个工作机会,对吧,卡特,她可以做任何事情,她只是读了这篇文章并联系起来。
She said, I have to meet these guys.
她说，我必须见见这些人。
And she probably turned down other things to meet with us and come and basically said, this one got my heart.
她可能会拒绝其他事情来与我们会面，然后过来基本上说，这个得到了我的心。
This got me.
这让我明白了。
The rhythm of this was different.
这节奏不一样了。
It melted my heart at the end.
最后融化了我的心。
It genuinely surprised me in the end.
最后这真的让我感到惊讶。
It's storytelling structure and the way it jumps around.
这是讲故事的结构和跳跃的方式。
And she had not gotten to do, you know, play with that sort of rhythm before.
你知道，她以前从未玩过这种节奏。
And she just, she, she wanted to direct it.
她只是，她，她想导演它。
She, she basically said, I want to do this.
她，她基本上是说，我想这样做。
And we didn't think we could get her.
我们认为我们无法得到她。
We did not think we could got her, but she kind of chose us, which was amazing.
我们不认为我们能得到她，但她选择了我们，这真是太棒了。
Yeah.
是的。
So let's, okay, so you've got this pilot.
那么，好吧，现在你已经有了这个飞行员。
It's Greenlit by, bought by 20th.
这是Greenlit by，20号买的。
It's Greenlit by CBS.
这是 CBS 的青睐。
They want to make a pilot.
他们想成为一名飞行员。
You scramble for your cast director.
你争夺你的演员导演。
You got the hottest multi-cam director in town in Pam Freiman.
帕姆·弗雷曼 (Pam ​​Freiman) 是城里最炙手可热的多机位导演。
And then you have to find your cast.
然后你必须找到你的演员阵容。
Yes.
是的。
And then let's talk about that.
然后我们来谈谈这个。
What was that?
那是什么？
Who was that?
那是谁？
Things went wrong.
事情出了问题。
That's where we finally had a break while because I can, this is where I joined the story.
这就是我们终于休息一下的地方，因为我可以，这就是我加入这个故事的地方。
Josh, tell your, I want your version of that story because you were day one, right?
乔希，告诉你，我想要你的那个故事版本，因为你是第一天，对吧？
This just doesn't.
这只是没有。
This is another, everything about the story of how much mother's creation, it never goes this way.
这是另外一个，关于母亲创作的故事的一切，从来都不是这样的。
Including this part.
包括这一部分。
Day one.
第一天。
The Tarranty version without cut to Josh's story.
塔兰蒂版本没有删减乔什的故事。
Yeah.
是的。
Back it up.
备份它。
Josh's story.
乔希的故事。
It's POV switch.
这是 POV 切换。
Himium style with pan flashback.
Himium 风格与平底锅闪回。
So, yeah, I'll just say I got out of NYU graduate acting program in 1999.
所以，是的，我只是说我在 1999 年从纽约大学表演研究生课程毕业。
I was doing a lot of theater.
我做了很多戏剧表演。
I was on Broadway.
我在百老汇。
I had done three pilots or four pilots.
我已经完成了三名或四名飞行员。
I can't remember my first one I got replaced on.
我不记得我的第一个被替换的了。
The second one got canceled after six episodes.
第二部在六集后被取消。
The third one never got picked up by NBC, a pilot I did with Rob Reiner.
第三个节目从未被 NBC 播出，是我和 Rob Reiner 一起制作的试播节目。
And yeah, so how I met him other I think was my fourth pilot, I had gotten in the place where I was really good at booking them kind of quickly, like I kind of cracked the algorithm a little bit, like I knew.
是的，所以我是如何认识他的，我认为是我的第四个飞行员，我已经进入了一个非常擅长快速预订的地方，就像我稍微破解了算法一样，就像我所知道的那样。
And I also was very good at determining, like, okay, I'm good for this role.
我也非常善于确定，好吧，我很适合这个角色。
I'm kind of the right person for this role.
我是这个角色的合适人选。
And I remember how I met your mother being something that, and maybe this is in hindsight, but I remember reading it, and I just was like, I know how to play this guy.
我记得我是如何认识你母亲的，也许这是事后诸葛亮，但我记得读过它，我只是想，我知道如何扮演这个家伙。
Like I absolutely know how to play this guy.
就像我完全知道如何扮演这个家伙一样。
I know where the jokes are.
我知道笑话在哪里。
I know where the rhythm is.
我知道节奏在哪里。
I know when to get sincere, I know when to undercut the sincerity with a joke, like I just understood how you guys had written him, and I understood it in some sort of like cellular way, and I remember going over it with a friend because for the audition, and I read through it like twice, and I just knew it, I memorized it.
我知道什么时候该表现出真诚，我知道什么时候用一个笑话削弱诚意，就像我刚刚理解你们是如何写他的一样，我以某种类似细胞的方式理解它，我记得因为试镜而和一个朋友一起复习了它，我读了两遍，我只是知道它，我记住了它。
And I have found as an actor, I've run this through with a lot of other actors, the better the writing, the easier to memorize because it's psychologically makes sense, like your next right move is the next right line that you want.
我发现，作为一名演员，我和很多其他演员都经历过这一点，写作越好，就越容易记住，因为它在心理上是有意义的，就像你的下一个正确的举动就是你想要的下一个正确的台词一样。
And when something's poorly written, it's almost like it has a hard time sticking to your ribs, right?
当某些东西写得不好时，就好像它很难粘在你的肋骨上，对吧？
So I just knew that I knew how to play the guy.
所以我只知道我知道如何扮演这个人。
And the two scenes that I was supposed to audition with, it was Kobe in the bar or Robin at that time in the bar when she throws a drink in my face, right?
我应该试镜的两个场景，是科比在酒吧，或者罗宾当时在酒吧，她把饮料泼到我脸上，对吗？
Yeah, absolutely.
是的，绝对是。
Yeah.
是的。
And then after the date gone awry where I have the model onto her, I stuck it being single, but I'd be a really good husband, right?
然后在约会出了问题之后，我把模特放在了她身上，我坚持单身，但我会是一个非常好的丈夫，对吧？
Yeah.
是的。
So I remember I woke up that morning.
所以我记得那天早上我醒来了。
It was early mid January.
那是一月初中旬。
So one of my first pilot auditions of the season, it was raining.
所以我本赛季的第一次试镜之一正在下雨。
I remember that day.
我记得那天。
And I was bummed because I've always been like, what's the opposite of the pathetic fallacy?
我很沮丧，因为我一直想，这个可悲的谬论的反面是什么？
Like I look towards the weather to tell me what's going to go, what's going to have it.
就像我期待天气来告诉我将会发生什么，将会发生什么一样。
And I thought, no, this is supposed to be my good audition day.
我想，不，这应该是我试镜的好日子。
It can't be raining.
不可能下雨。
But I got there.
但我到了那里。
I walk in.
我走进去。
And yet rain is an important part of the whole series.
然而，雨是整个系列的重要组成部分。
That's true.
这是真的。
I walk in Megan Bramman, the cast director, you two, Pam and Rob Greenberg, right?
我走在梅根·布拉曼（Megan Bramman）身上，演员导演，你们两个，帕姆（Pam）和罗布·格林伯格（Rob Greenberg），对吧？
Who was kind of, was he, was he assigned to you guys as like a wiser steadier hand, like, like a older, yes, that's he looked like.
他是谁，是不是，他被分配给你们，就像一个更明智、更稳定的手，就像一个年长的人，是的，这就是他的样子。
But he was a Frazier writer is like what a zookeeper is to Chimps that's what Rob was.
但他是一位弗雷泽作家，就像动物园管理员之于黑猩猩，这就是罗布。
Yeah.
是的。
So that was the room.
这就是房间。
A zookeeper who sometimes flings his own poop.
动物园管理员有时会乱扔自己的粪便。
Yeah, but Dylan was in the room, right?
是的，但是迪伦在房间里，对吧？
Dylan was videotaping it.
迪伦正在录像。
Megan Brandon, the cast raker, you guys Pam and Rob.
梅根·布兰登（Megan Brandon），演员阵容，你们帕姆（Pam）和罗布（Rob）。
I remember a little bit of chit chat about Ohio with Carter, right?
我记得和卡特有过一些关于俄亥俄州的闲聊，对吧？
Yeah, I mean, I mean, can we can we now flat because I'll just to drop in like, oh, sure me, right?
是的，我的意思是，我的意思是，我们现在可以平躺吗，因为我只是顺便过来一下，哦，当然可以，对吧？
Okay, so now we're gonna, we're popping back and forth.
好吧，现在我们要来回走动。
We're gonna go ahead.
我们要继续前进。
It's very him, man.
这就是他，伙计。
For me personally, like, you know, Craig and I, we, you know, at the risk of, like, like we, we never set out to make something that's like autobiographical.
就我个人而言，就像，你知道，克雷格和我，我们，你知道，冒着像我们一样的风险，我们从未打算制作类似自传的东西。
Like we didn't name the characters Carter and Craig, but there was like, we, we, it was a big starting point of single guy, guy, and guy who's just gotten engaged.
就像我们没有给角色命名卡特和克雷格一样，但就像，我们，我们，这是一个单身男人、男人和刚刚订婚的男人的一个重要起点。
That was a big starting point And it was, we were especially coming from, it was in a time in comedy, like coming from writing American dad, when there was a lot of snark and a lot of like, a lot of, not in a bad way, but like a lot of like, like shocking comedy and comedy that's kind of mean and zingers and stuff like that.
那是一个很大的起点，我们特别来自，那是一个喜剧时代，就像写《美国爸爸》一样，当时有很多讽刺和很多类似的东西，很多，不是坏的方式，而是很多类似的东西，比如令人震惊的喜剧和有点刻薄、搞笑的喜剧之类的东西。
And the scary part of writing this was, it was very vulnerable and was very honest.
写这篇文章的可怕之处在于，它非常脆弱，而且非常诚实。
And it was very true.
这是非常真实的。
And it felt like, especially that speech that Ted gives.
感觉就像是，尤其是特德发表的那场演讲。
I remember feeling like feeling like this was like a page out of my diary and I felt like I was writing something that was kind of about my life at that time.
我记得感觉这就像我日记中的一页，我觉得我正在写一些关于我当时生活的东西。
I had been dating for a while.
我已经约会了一段时间了。
I had like had a bunch of, you know, romantic mishaps here and there like anyone does and I was at a point where I was like, I'm, I just, I'm ready for the, I'm ready for the big time but I can't find the right person.
我和其他人一样，经历过很多浪漫的不幸，我当时想，我，我只是，我已经准备好了，我已经准备好了，但我找不到合适的人。
And so all of that got poured into that speech and it was the kind of thing that like I would think about my fellow writers that American dad reading the speech and thinking like, oh God, this is, but that's what makes it good.
所以所有这些都被倾注到了那次演讲中，就像我会想到我的作家同行，美国爸爸读了演讲，然后想，天哪，这就是，但这就是它的优点。
And that's why, you know, if it's scary, that's why you have to, I think Arthur really said something like the writing, the best writing is the stuff that humiliates you as you're writing it.
这就是为什么，你知道，如果它很可怕，那就是为什么你必须这么做，我认为亚瑟确实说过类似写作的东西，最好的写作就是在你写的时候羞辱你的东西。
Oh yeah.
哦，是的。
Yeah.
是的。
For sure.
一定。
100%.
100%。
And so that like that speech, hearing, we had never heard that speech allowed.
因此，就像那个演讲、听证会一样，我们从未听过那个演讲被允许。
And okay.
好吧。
So I'm going to, I'm going to now give a little context to you walking in the room, which was, we got a casting director, Megan Brandman, and she said, she, like, first thing, first meeting, I've got Ted.
所以我现在要给你们在房间里走动提供一些背景信息，我们有一位选角导演梅根·布兰德曼，她说，她，就像，第一次见面，我有泰德。
I've got your Ted.
我找到了你的特德。
I have no idea who Robyn's going to be.
我不知道罗宾会是谁。
I've got some ideas for Barney.
我对巴尼有一些想法。
I've got some ideas for Marshall Lilly.
我对马歇尔·莉莉有一些想法。
I've got Ted.
我有特德。
We're like, okay, and I'm thinking like, oh, you found a guy from Ohio who went to a liberal arts school like Wesleyan, which, you know, Kenyan is very, you know, I almost went to Kenyan, they're very, very comfortable.
我们就像，好吧，我在想，哦，你找到了一个来自俄亥俄州的人，他去了卫斯理安这样的文科学校，你知道，肯尼亚非常，你知道，我差点就去了肯尼亚，他们非常非常舒服。
Like I'm sure you really have Ted and then so the, but then sure enough, first day of casting, first audition.
就像我确信你真的有泰德一样，然后，果然，选角的第一天，第一次试镜。
Like it was the first.
就像是第一次一样。
Right.
正确的。
Yeah, for day one audition one, John, raining outside in Los Angeles, Josh Radner walks through the doors.
是的，第一天试镜，约翰，洛杉矶外面下着雨，乔什·拉德纳走进了大门。
If he's brought New York with him, I think the rain was perfect.
如果他把纽约也带来了，我认为这场雨是完美的。
You brought New York into the totally.
你把纽约彻底带入了这个世界。
Yeah.
是的。
And and first time we had heard these scenes out loud read by actors by, you know, by anyone other than us, you know, in our inner, in the privacy of our little like writer studio wherever we were.
我们第一次听到演员大声朗读这些场景，你知道，除了我们之外的任何人，你知道，在我们内心深处，在我们小小的作家工作室的隐私中，无论我们身在何处。
So, it was like, it was a big moment.
所以，这就像，这是一个重要的时刻。
And this old man, he must have me, fell in love with you, knew he was your city.
而这个老人，他一定有我，爱上了你，知道他是你的城市。
And now, commercials.
现在，广告。
As a young adult, finding the right path to your future can feel overwhelming.
作为一个年轻人，找到通往未来的正确道路可能会让人感到不知所措。
It starts with Year Up United's tuition-free job training program, Career Pathways.
它始于 Year Up United 的免学费职业培训计划“职业道路”。
If you're without a bachelor's degree, but have a high school diploma or GED, you can get skills first training to succeed in the industries you're passionate about, all while earning a weekly educational stipend to offset basic expenses.
如果您没有学士学位，但拥有高中文凭或 GED，您可以获得技能优先培训，以便在您热衷的行业中取得成功，同时每周赚取教育津贴来抵消基本费用。
From there, you'll have access to internships and hands-on experiences with Fortune 500 And with Year Up United's job placement services and personalized coaching and mentorship, you can put your knowledge, skills, and most importantly confidence into practice.
从那里，您将有机会获得《财富 500 强》的实习机会和实践经验，并通过 Year Up United 的就业安置服务以及个性化辅导和指导，您可以将您的知识、技能和最重要的信心付诸实践。
Apply to Year Up United today and take the first step toward achieving the career you want.
立即申请 Year Up United，迈出实现您想要的职业生涯的第一步。
Visit YearUp.org to learn more.
访问 YearUp.org 了解更多信息。
Hey, Alec.
嘿，亚历克。
Hey, Josh.
嘿，乔什。
I'm pretty excited for this autumn.
我对这个秋天感到非常兴奋。
Can I tell you why?
我可以告诉你为什么吗？
Absolutely.
绝对地。
It's a lovely time in New York City.
这是纽约市的美好时光。
Well, yeah, I've got a new album coming out and I have a single that's coming out and it's called October.
嗯，是的，我有一张新专辑即将发行，还有一首单曲即将发行，它的名字叫《十月》。
What?
什么？
We're hearing about it right here for the first time, so I'm very excited about the fall about the autumn, especially the month of October, and not only am I excited about the music, I'm excited to get comfortable and cozy because that's with fall on the East Coast or whatever place you are that has seasons is all about.
我们是第一次在这里听到这个消息，所以我对秋天感到非常兴奋，尤其是十月，我不仅对音乐感到兴奋，而且对变得舒适和温馨感到兴奋，因为这就是东海岸或任何有季节的地方的秋天。
We don't need to argue about this.
我们不需要争论这个。
There are seasons in Los Angeles and and every night it's fall That's true.
洛杉矶有季节之分，每天晚上都是秋天，这是真的。
That's true.
这是真的。
You need a light jacket if you live in California Where can you get those light jackets and those sweaters and those perfect autumn comfortable and cozy pieces might I recommend quince, which sent me an incredible sweater that is in heavy rotation also I picked out one or actually Jordan I picked it out a Sweater from quince that is also in heavy rotation so we are set For the fall, we keep going back to these sweaters.
如果你住在加利福尼亚州，你需要一件轻便的夹克，你在哪里可以买到那些轻便的夹克和毛衣以及那些完美的秋季舒适和温馨的衣服，我可以推荐木瓜，它给我寄来了一件令人难以置信的毛衣，而且我也挑选了一件，或者实际上是乔丹，我从木瓜那里挑选了一件毛衣，它也在大量轮换，所以我们准备在秋天，我们继续回到这些毛衣。
They work with almost our entire, I mean, our entire closet is just earth tones because that's kind of what we work with.
它们几乎与我们的整个衣橱配合，我的意思是，我们的整个衣柜都是大地色，因为这就是我们的工作方式。
But it matches with everything.
但它与一切都很相配。
So we're delighted with our pieces from Quince and I think you would be too.
因此，我们对 Quince 的作品感到非常满意，我想您也会如此。
So upgrade your everyday.
所以升级你的日常生活。
Download the Quince app for app exclusive offers or go to quince.com slash your mother pod.
下载 Quince 应用程序以获得应用程序独家优惠，或访问 quince.com 削减你的母豆荚。
Get free shipping on your order and 365 day returns now available in Canada and the UK too.
加拿大和英国现在也提供订单免费送货和 365 天退货服务。
That's q-u-i-n-c-e dot com slash your mother pod.
这就是 q-u-i-n-c-e . com 削减你的母亲 pod。
And of commercials back to show.
和广告回来展示。
And then we cut to Josh walking in the door.
然后我们切到乔什走进门。
Josh's POV.
乔什的视角。
Yeah.
是的。
So I remember, I remember we talked about Ohio.
所以我记得，我记得我们谈论过俄亥俄州。
I remember it just being like one of those auditions.
我记得这就像那些试镜之一。
And back then, I was auditioning a lot.
那时，我参加了很多试镜。
Like I was not, I gotten pretty good at it.
就像我不是一样，我已经做得很好了。
Like I knew how to walk into a room.
就像我知道如何走进一个房间一样。
I knew how to do the minimal amount of chitchat that was effective and not too much.
我知道如何进行最少量的有效闲聊，而不是太多。
And I, but I do remember doing the first scene, it went great.
而我，但我确实记得拍第一个场景，效果很棒。
The vibe in the room was terrific.
房间里的气氛棒极了。
I remember that felt really good.
我记得那感觉真的很好。
And I remember on the, when I hit that speech, I could feel Pam and I think Megan, like I could feel part of the way you know, and I think I felt you guys too, but I felt like, oh, this is where they wanted the speech to live, like this is what I think they wrote and I gave them what they're looking for.
我记得，当我发表演讲时，我能感觉到帕姆，我想梅根，就像我能感觉到你们所知道的方式的一部分，我想我也感觉到了你们，但我觉得，哦，这就是他们想要演讲的地方，就像我认为这就是他们写的，我给了他们他们想要的东西。
And I don't remember if you guys had me do the scenes with any adjustments, I might have just read them once.
我不记得你们是否让我对场景进行了任何调整，我可能只读过一次。
You remember when Megan said to you, what Megan said to you after you finished that speech?
你还记得梅根对你说的话，在你演讲结束后梅根对你说了什么吗？
Oh, did she say, well, you marry me?
哦，她有没有说，好吧，你嫁给我吧？
She said, well, you marry me.
她说，好吧，你嫁给我吧。
Yeah.
是的。
That's what I got to propose.
这就是我要提议的。
So that's a good.
所以这是一件好事。
If for those young actors out there, yes, if you audition and you got to propose you with the guest manager, you're probably going to get that right.
如果对于那些年轻演员来说，是的，如果你试镜并且你必须向客座经理推荐你，你可能会做对的。
Yeah.
是的。
You call your agent afterwards.
之后你打电话给你的经纪人。
You say, well, I did this whole speech.
你说，好吧，整个演讲都是我做的。
And afterwards, the cast director said, will you marry me?
然后演员导演说，你愿意嫁给我吗？
Do you think that's a good sign?
你认为这是一个好兆头吗？
Oh, so we all wanted to marry you.
哦，所以我们都想嫁给你。
We all felt that way.
我们都有这样的感觉。
We were you melted our hearts.
我们是你融化了我们的心。
So I remember going back to my car.
所以我记得回到我的车里。
And so this is very inside baseball, and I don't even know if it's still this way, but you used to have to test for the studio and test for the network theory, these two hoops, if you got past the initial producer session, which is what I had with you guys.
所以这是棒球内部的事情，我什至不知道是否仍然如此，但是如果你通过了最初的制作人会议，这就是我和你们一起进行的，那么你过去必须测试工作室并测试网络理论，这两个圈子。
So I, oh, also this is maybe worth mentioning.
所以我，哦，这也许也值得一提。
My agent at the time, who I was with for about 14 years, she used to tell me the only power you have as a young actor is the ability to say no, and I didn't have much power.
我当时的经纪人，和我在一起大约 14 年，她经常告诉我，作为一名年轻演员，你唯一的权力就是拒绝的能力，而我没有太多权力。
I didn't, I wasn't a known actor.
我没有，我不是一个知名演员。
I was known in the business, cast New Actors New Me, a couple of showrunners New Me.
我在业内很出名，演员阵容包括新演员新我、几位节目主持人新我。
But I had gotten a reputation as being like a little picky as a young actor.
但作为一名年轻演员，我被认为有点挑剔。
And I remember Megan had pitched.
我记得梅根已经投过球了。
We were told that by Megan.
梅根告诉我们这一点。
Yeah, Megan had pitched.
是的，梅根已经投球了。
I really wanted to tell that.
我真的很想告诉你这一点。
I don't know if he'll come in.
我不知道他是否会进来。
He's picky.
他很挑剔。
So when you saw me on the list, you're like, oh, Josh Radder's going to like you.
所以当你在名单上看到我时，你会想，哦，乔什·雷德会喜欢你的。
So we felt accepted by you.
所以我们感觉被你接受了。
We were like, he liked us.
我们就像，他喜欢我们。
The picky guy liked us.
那个挑剔的家伙喜欢我们。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
We were so needy.
我们是如此需要帮助。
So that was a real gift my agent gave me was saying like, be discerning, you know?
所以这是我的经纪人给我的一份真正的礼物，就像是说，要有洞察力，你知道吗？
So I would only throw my hat in the rings for stuff I really believed in.
所以我只会为我真正相信的事情而奋斗。
And I believed in your show.
我相信你的表演。
By the time I got back to the car, my agent called me and she said, well, that was quick.
当我回到车上时，我的经纪人打电话给我，她说，好吧，那很快。
They want to do a test deal with you.
他们想与你进行测试交易。
They want to take you to the studio.
他们想带你去工作室。
Your car was 10 feet away.
你的车在 10 英尺外。
So then you guys also had a couple more days of seeing other Ted's, right?
那么你们还有几天时间去见其他特德，对吧？
We had to keep seeing other Ted's even though we knew It's so shitty, I feel bad, because we knew we had you, and then other people come in, and nobody could be you.
我们不得不继续见到其他特德，尽管我们知道这太糟糕了，我感觉很糟糕，因为我们知道我们拥有你，然后其他人进来，没有人可以成为你。
Great actors, great people came in, and you need to go into the studio with a few, and network to test, to go into a room with the executives and have you, and as it turned out, Kobe, do chemistry reads and see, we had to have that happen with a couple of other people, but we knew we were in love with you.
伟大的演员，伟大的人进来了，你需要和一些人一起进入工作室，并进行网络测试，进入一个与高管一起的房间并拥有你，结果是，科比，做化学阅读并看看，我们必须与其他几个人一起发生这种情况，但我们知道我们爱上了你。
All of us were, and that's harrowing, because we could have had a different feeling the network.
我们所有人都是如此，这令人痛苦，因为我们可能会对网络有不同的感觉。
The network could have been like, no, it's not him.
网络可能会说，不，不是他。
And that would have been so heartbreaking.
那真是令人心碎。
But everybody you went after the other went, we get it.
但每个人都追随另一个人，我们明白了。
And that doesn't always happen.
但这并不总是发生。
Either kids, that does not always happen.
无论是孩子，这并不总是发生。
Yeah.
是的。
Well, I've found in in show business, and maybe it's like this in other areas of life.
嗯，我在演艺界发现了这一点，也许生活的其他领域也是如此。
But if a job is not yours, the door won't open.
但如果工作不是你的，门就不会打开。
It just simply won't open.
它只是打不开。
No matter how right you think you are for it, how much you want it, If the job is yours, the doors keep flying open and I've learned to trust effortlessness in my career, like when you click with people and it's easy and fun and you're all just the enthusiasm is really high.
无论你认为自己有多正确，你有多想要它，如果这份工作是你的，大门就会一直敞开，我学会了相信我的职业生涯毫不费力，就像当你与人相处时，这很容易、很有趣，而且你们都热情很高。
You want to make this thing.
你想做这个东西。
I don't, I sometimes think effort, like hard grinding effort can be a little overrated.
我不这么认为，我有时认为努力，比如艰苦的努力可能有点被高估了。
That you need to pay attention to where things are actually in flow.
你需要注意事情实际上在哪里进行。
Yeah, absolutely.
是的，绝对是。
And that's cool to hear you say that because I, you know, from the, and you've now been on both sides of the table, having, having written and directed your own movies and stuff, like, it is like you, at the beginning of these sessions, you get this list.
听到你这么说真是太酷了，因为我，你知道，从那时开始，你现在已经站在了谈判桌的两边，编写和导演了自己的电影和东西，就像你一样，在这些会议开始时，你得到了这个清单。
And, you know, and here's who we're seeing today.
而且，你知道，这就是我们今天看到的人。
And it's like a list and it's like a name and then a little space for you to write your comments.
它就像一个列表，就像一个名字，然后是一个供您写评论的小空间。
And so it's just like a very clean sheet of paper with like nine names.
所以它就像一张非常干净的纸，上面有九个名字。
And you just like see that And you think like these are like nine people right now just hoping that that they're like and it's by the way, it's this like nine different branches of like where the universe could go.
你只是喜欢看到这一点 你认为这些就像现在的九个人只是希望他们就像，顺便说一句，这就像宇宙可以去的九个不同的分支。
This could be a show with this person as Ted and this person as Ted and it's it's yeah.
这可能是一个节目，这个人是特德，这个人是特德，是的。
And I feel like there's it's a lot of the stuff we talked about on how many your mother because just the fact that like Destiny so it takes such a big part in in the search for love.
我觉得我们谈论了很多关于你母亲的事情，因为就像《命运》一样，它在寻找爱的过程中扮演了如此重要的角色。
you know, I feel like how I met your mother at its core is like, it's this struggle between is falling in love something that I go out and seek.
你知道，我觉得我遇见你母亲的本质就像是，这种斗争就是坠入爱河，我出去寻找。
Do I take action to meet the person that I spend the rest of my life with?
我是否会采取行动去见那个与我共度余生的人？
Or is it something that happens to me?
或者是发生在我身上的事情？
I have to just sit back and let it happen.
我必须坐下来让它发生。
And that's like, that's the casting process.
这就是选角过程。
I mean, it really is like, I feel like there's no way to, there's no answer to that.
我的意思是，这真的是，我觉得没有办法，没有答案。
It's an unsolvable question.
这是一个无解的问题。
There's a good theme.
有一个很好的主题。
A good theme has emerged of our conversation of just like, there's some preparation and then there's some luck in letting you and leading it to that part too.
我们的谈话出现了一个很好的主题，就像，有一些准备，然后有一些运气让你也把它带到那部分。
And your reaction writing too, it's like you can't, if you're forcing it too hard, that might be a sign and it's not quite right.
你的反应也是如此，就像你不能，如果你强迫得太用力，这可能是一个迹象，而且不太正确。
And the doors did keep opening for you.
大门确实一直为你敞开。
In some ways, you guys had to honor the themes of your show and the creation of your show.
在某些方面，你们必须尊重节目的主题和节目的创作。
Yeah.
是的。
Do you know what I'm saying?
你知道我在说什么吗？
Like, you had to be open to like the right person at the right time.
就像，你必须开放地在正确的时间喜欢正确的人。
Yeah.
是的。
So I'm trying to remember.
所以我努力回忆。
I go to the studio, you had one other guy there.
我去了工作室，那里还有另外一个人。
I think another 10.
我想还有10个。
Yeah, the other guy was who we say it was.
是的，另一个人就是我们所说的那个人。
We can say it was it was Bob Sagitt.
我们可以说是鲍勃·萨吉特。
He was a little too old for the role and that's why he became a future 10.
他对于这个角色来说有点太老了，这就是他成为未来十号的原因。
A consolation prize.
安慰奖。
Yeah, it was, he was really good, but it's like, here's a little old.
是的，他确实很棒，但感觉有点老了。
But now, now I know.
但现在，现在我知道了。
I don't think we should say names of who it would be.
我认为我们不应该说出是谁的名字。
No, no, no, that's not what I was saying.
不不不，我不是这个意思。
And everything was just lies.
而一切都只是谎言。
But very talented, another very tough guy.
但非常有才华，也是一个非常硬朗的人。
You know, I'm just gonna, can I just throw this in?
你知道，我只是想，我可以把这个扔进去吗？
It's someone, I remember being there.
是一个人，我记得在那儿。
And because you go to these things, and there's two, there's always two, and everyone in the room, including the head executives at CBS, everybody knows, there's the guy that they want, and then there's the other guy that they're bringing in, just to show like, yeah, but we really want this guy.
因为你去这些事情，有两个，总是有两个，房间里的每个人，包括哥伦比亚广播公司的首席执行官，每个人都知道，他们想要一个人，然后他们引进另一个人，只是为了表明，是的，但我们真的想要这个人。
And I think everyone knew that, including both of the actors involved.
我想每个人都知道这一点，包括涉及的两位演员。
And I remember feeling just because my mind always says, like how can I have more anxiety about this moment?
我记得这种感觉只是因为我的大脑总是在说，我怎样才能对这一刻感到更加焦虑？
Okay, I'll feel bad for this guy.
好吧，我会为这个人感到难过。
And I remember because he was really, and I'm not to say who he was, but he went on to be super funny and great on another show.
我记得因为他确实是，我不是说他是谁，但他在另一场节目中表现得非常有趣和出色。
That was, that I was a huge fan on it.
也就是说，我是它的超级粉丝。
And so it was, it was, it worked out right.
事情就是这样，事情确实如此，结果是正确的。
It was nice to see that.
很高兴看到这一点。
Can I say the, I do know this story that really made me laugh.
我可以说，我确实知道这个让我发笑的故事。
It's a Rob Greenberg line because I think I also had to read a Barney scene.
这是罗布·格林伯格的台词，因为我想我还必须读一下巴尼的场景。
It was, it was Barney trying to get me to go to laser tag or something in the test.
是的，巴尼试图让我参加激光枪战或其他测试。
and Rob Greenberg apparently said afterwards about the other guy, I feel like he wants to go to laser tag, like he would go to laser tag.
罗布·格林伯格后来显然谈到了另一个人，我觉得他想去激光枪战，就像他会去激光枪战一样。
I really think Josh did not want to go to laser tag with this guy.
我真的认为乔什不想和这个家伙一起去激光枪战。
Yeah, yeah, yeah, really a little jockier, a little different energy.
是啊，是啊，是啊，真的有点兴奋，有点不同的能量。
Yeah, yeah, yeah, it had to be plausible that you would not have gone.
是啊，是啊，是啊，你不会走一定是有道理的。
And you would not have gone to laser tag and that's why you were right.
你不会去激光标记，这就是为什么你是对的。
No, I'm just curious, like, just when people become so important and kind of iconic in your life, like there's that moment when you, when you see them for the first time that kind of gets etched in in your own personal history, like I'm just curious what, how you envisioned Robyn Sherbatsky.
不，我只是好奇，就像，当人们在你的生活中变得如此重要和具有标志性时，就像你第一次看到他们的那一刻，那种感觉被铭刻在你自己的个人历史中，就像我只是好奇你是如何想象罗宾·谢尔巴茨基的。
I don't know if that was her last name in the pilot, was it?
我不知道这是否是她在飞行员中的姓氏，是吗？
I think you came up with that letter.
我想那封信是你想出来的。
Yeah, it's, it was, it was a Sherb, Robyn Kitty Sherbatsky is a character from Anna Karenina, I think.
是的，它是，它是，它是一个 Sherb，我认为 Robyn Kitty Sherbatsky 是《安娜·卡列尼娜》中的角色。
I like, I think I was like, thought I'd, I mean, I painted myself a reader and And I was like, I'm going to read Anna Karenina and got like 20 pages into it.
我喜欢，我想我想，我想，我的意思是，我把自己画成一个读者，我想，我要读《安娜·卡列尼娜》，读了大约 20 页。
And then, yeah, yeah, exactly.
然后，是的，是的，完全正确。
So you told Stoy, I got you.
所以你告诉斯托伊，我抓住你了。
Did you have an idea in your head of who this woman was?
你心里知道这个女人是谁吗？
It's interesting because you've got five main characters.
这很有趣，因为你有五个主角。
Four of them were absolutely drawn from real life.
其中四个绝对取材于现实生活。
Like Ted Marshall and Lily were me, Craig and Rebecca, you know, and again, like, then then it becomes some kind of the writers come in and like add their own hang their own stuff on the Christmas tree.
就像特德·马歇尔和莉莉是我一样，克雷格和丽贝卡，你知道，然后又变成了某种作家进来，喜欢在圣诞树上添加他们自己的东西。
But and Barney was very much inspired by a couple guys that sort of wore that kind of false staffian presence in our lives when we lived in New York.
但是，当我们住在纽约时，巴尼受到了一些人的启发，他们在我们的生活中扮演着一种假职员的角色。
The only character who was completely made up whole cloth was Robin.
唯一一个完全由整块布组成的角色是罗宾。
And so it really was like the casting process was sort of this process of like, let's see if we can find her.
所以选角过程真的就像是这样的过程，让我们看看是否能找到她。
Let's see who this could be.
让我们看看这可能是谁。
It really was like, it wasn't like, oh yeah, I mean, I haven't noticed like, I think Neil got cast as Barney despite the fact that he sort of was physically nothing like the, the, the people that Barney was, was based on, but like that, you know, I remember you guys talking around Jack Black as a prototype.
这真的就像，哦，是的，我的意思是，我没有注意到，我认为尼尔被选为巴尼，尽管事实上他的身体状况与巴尼的原型完全不同，但就像那样，你知道，我记得你们谈论杰克·布莱克作为原型。
Like yeah, I think you saw him much more like a fast road that was bigger and yeah, yeah, there was, there was like a Vince Vaughn road and like a Jack Black road, but we were more down the Jack Black road, I think that wouldn't you say Carter and then like, you know, came and it was like, shit, that's too good.
是的，我想你看到他更像是一条更大的快速道路，是的，是的，有，就像文斯·沃恩路和杰克·布莱克路，但我们更多的是沿着杰克·布莱克路，我想你不会说卡特，然后就像，你知道，来了，就像，妈的，那太好了。
It's too good.
太好了。
But I do think the one insight that I think we happened upon that I'm proud of us for happening upon was this feeling because of course you get picked up and of course the first thing is like, who can we get in it that will help its chances of getting on the air?
但我确实认为，我认为我们偶然发现的一个让我感到自豪的洞察力就是这种感觉，因为当然你会被接住，当然第一件事就是，我们可以让谁加入来帮助它有机会播出？
Who's famous?
谁有名？
But there was a feeling like I remember thinking like so much of Robin is built into this moment where Ted looks across the crowded bar and sees this person.
但我记得有一种感觉，就像罗宾的大部分内容都融入到了泰德穿过拥挤的酒吧并看到这个人的那一刻。
and we see her for the first time as Ted Singer for the first time.
我们第一次看到她以泰德·辛格的身份出现。
And if it's someone that you already have this built-in expectation of, like, oh, I loved her in this, right?
如果你已经对这个人有这种内在的期望，比如，哦，我爱她，对吧？
I hate her in that.
我讨厌她这一点。
Like, you're already, you're outside of the moment, and you're not having that.
就像，你已经在这一刻之外了，而你却没有那样的感觉。
It's not that moment of like, there's a mystery here to be solved.
这不是那个时刻，这里有一个谜团需要解开。
I want to get to know this person.
我想认识这个人。
But it can't be like, you see, you see a person and you're like, I know what you did last summer.
但它不能像，你看，你看到一个人，你就像，我知道你去年夏天做了什么。
It can't be.
不可能。
It has to be like, I have to know what they did last summer.
就像，我必须知道他们去年夏天做了什么。
You have to not know what they did any summer because tell me about your summer.
你不必知道他们每个夏天都做了什么，因为请告诉我你的夏天。
I think a mystery about me and Kobe's relative obscurity or anonymity at that point really served us.
我认为关于我和科比当时相对默默无闻或匿名的神秘感确实对我们很有帮助。
It served you guys in the story because you're, for sure, discovering these people, you're discovering them.
它对故事中的你们很有帮助，因为你们肯定正在发现这些人，你们正在发现他们。
And you want to feel like you, you've just happened upon them rather than having any, you know, sort of foreign knowledge of them.
你想要感觉自己只是偶然发现了它们，而不是对它们有任何外国知识。
Yeah, it was perfect who was more famous than who was not more famous in that of those five.
是的，这五个人中谁更有名，谁比谁不更有名，这是完美的。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思？
Like the perfect, the famous people fell into the right spots in the cast.
就像完美的人一样，名人在演员阵容中也处于正确的位置。
And we met you.
我们遇见了你。
The word met is in the title.
标题中有遇见这个词。
It's about meeting people.
这是关于与人见面。
We meet Ted.
我们见到了特德。
We never, we've never seen you before.
我们从来没有见过你。
We meet Robin.
我们遇见了罗宾。
And that you're right.
你是对的。
It was like the audience met you guys.
就像观众认识了你们一样。
But Carter, it also occurs to me when you're, when you're talking about Robin being invented out of whole cloth on some level, she was the woman you were hoping to meet, right?
但是卡特，当你谈论罗宾在某种程度上被完全创造出来时，我也想到了，她就是你希望见到的女人，对吧？
Like she was, you know, she became dimensional and spiky and all these things, but she was like, what if I looked across the bar and just spotted this woman?
就像她一样，你知道，她变得立体、尖锐等等，但她就像，如果我望向酒吧对面，刚刚发现这个女人怎么办？
What would she be?
她会是什么样子？
For sure.
一定。
Yeah.
是的。
She was built that way.
她就是这样建造的。
It was a combination of like, make her everything that would be like, of course, he falls in love with this person.
这是一种喜欢的结合，让她的一切都会像，当然，他爱上了这个人。
also give her things that it was almost like it's in sort of like judoing the like what's the tension of this series going to be like we've got this character this who just wants to you know his drive is fallen love he's like has this like he gets hit my lightning in this first episode of like Eureka I want to get married I'm like ready okay my friend just got engaged.
也给她一些东西，就像柔道一样，这个系列的紧张感是什么，我们有这个角色，他只是想让你知道他的动力是坠入爱河，他就像在《尤里卡》的第一集中被闪电击中，我想结婚，我准备好了，我的朋友刚刚订婚了。
I want to settle down.
我想安定下来。
Like, how do we create tension?
比如，我们如何制造紧张感？
And I feel like that sort of like naturally led to Robin just becoming this character that her central drive, at least at the beginning, is I don't want to settle that.
我觉得这种感觉很自然地导致罗宾成为这个角色，她的核心驱动力，至少在一开始，是我不想解决这个问题。
But I do remember by first seeing Kobe for the first time, down a hallway, walking towards me.
但我确实记得第一次见到科比，是在走廊里，向我走来。
And, you know, you just have to do all this, you know, chit chat.
而且，你知道，你只需要做这一切，你知道，闲聊。
And then you are supposed to, you know, simulate this thing together.
然后你们应该一起模拟这个东西。
But I do remember at, I think the network test.
但我确实记得，我认为是网络测试。
So it was just me by the time, I think you, you just brought me to the network.
所以当时只有我一个人，我想是你，你刚刚把我带到了网络上。
Is that right?
是这样吗？
Or did you bring both guys?
还是两个人都带了？
God, Carter, do you remember?
天哪，卡特，你还记得吗？
I feel like in the network, you have to still bring two people.
我感觉在网络里，还是得带两个人。
I feel like it's always, there's always another person I can't remember.
我总觉得，总有一个我记不起的人。
But maybe to see you by the point.
但也许是为了顺便见你。
Because when you were with Kobe in a scene, that was the network, I think, and that was probably just you guys.
因为当你和科比一起出现在一个场景中时，我认为那就是网络，而那可能只是你们。
Oh, yeah.
哦，是的。
That was okay.
没关系。
So maybe the studio is a big deal.
所以也许工作室很重要。
That's the last step before you were officially hired.
这是您被正式聘用之前的最后一步。
Yeah.
是的。
But I do remember I had gotten, I kind of would would get these waves of heroic confidence, like the higher stakes it got, I would get like a little more like, I'm going to get this, you know, like it was my, this competitive street came out in me, and I would And sometimes say things that were like just a little like Hutzpahey in a way that was like risky, but I remember when Kobe, she threw an actual drink in my face.
但我确实记得我已经得到了，我会得到这些英雄般的自信，就像它得到的赌注越高，我会变得更像，我会得到这个，你知道，就像这是我的，这条竞争性的街道在我身上出现，有时我会以一种冒险的方式说一些有点像Hutzpahey的话，但我记得当科比时，她把一杯真正的饮料泼到我脸上。
She had some water and she threw the water in my face and everyone laughed.
她拿了一些水，把水泼到我脸上，每个人都笑了。
And I, this seems over at that point.
而我，似乎到那时就结束了。
And I turned to the brass at CBS in 20th and I said, as if this process weren't humiliating enough.
20 日，我向哥伦比亚广播公司的高层求助，我说，好像这个过程还不够丢脸。
And it got, you know, it got this like really big laugh.
你知道，它得到了很大的笑声。
And I felt, um, I felt like that was good.
我觉得，嗯，我觉得那很好。
You know, I just want them to know like, I just wanted that I, I, I, I always hated the power imbalance in being an actor and saying, like, please give me this role.
你知道，我只是想让他们知道，我只是想让我，我，我，我一直讨厌作为一名演员的权力不平衡，并说，就像，请给我这个角色。
And I always wanted them to know like, I got something going on here.
我一直想让他们知道，我这里发生了一些事情。
Yeah.
是的。
I hope you understand.
我希望你能理解。
So I just wanted to level it the tiniest bit because it's so, it's so outsized the power when you walk in there.
所以我只是想把它调平一点，因为当你走进那里时，它的力量是如此之大。
And there are these executives that run empires.
还有这些管理帝国的高管。
Seated in like bleacher level, like theater seating, like tiered seating.
坐在露天看台的位置，像剧院的座位，像分层的座位。
Like it's a little fee, a little play just for them.
就像是一点费用，只为他们玩一点。
The whole thing stage managed to make you nervous.
整个舞台让你紧张。
It's not comfortable.
这不太舒服。
It's very stressful.
压力很大。
And it's on purpose.
这是故意的。
They want to see that you can, you can rise to like be like really like under the gun and there's pressure in the air in that room.
他们希望看到你可以，你可以在枪口下表现得像真的一样，房间里的空气充满压力。
And Carter and I, of course, feel like total frauds.
当然，卡特和我感觉自己完全是个骗子。
We're sitting in these bleachers with all these executives.
我们和所有这些高管坐在看台上。
Meanwhile, two months earlier, we're the people, you know, bringing our little script to them.
与此同时，两个月前，我们就是把我们的小剧本带给他们的人。
Like, please, you know, we were the you a month earlier.
就像，拜托，你知道，我们是一个月前的你。
And now we're in the judge e-seats.
现在我们坐在电子评委席上。
And so like, I felt I had such empathy for you in that moment, but you were great.
就像，那一刻我觉得我对你很有同情心，但你很棒。
And human Kobe, the energy of human Kobe, undeniable.
还有人类科比，人类科比的能量，不可否认。
I did feel loved and supported by you guys, by Pam, by Rob Greenberg, by Megan and Dylan.
我确实感受到了你们、帕姆、罗布·格林伯格、梅根和迪伦的爱和支持。
Like I felt like the people that I had established this rapport within that first room were really on my side.
我觉得在第一个房间里与我建立融洽关系的人真的站在我这边。
So I felt really, I felt some wind at my sales.
所以我真的觉得我的销售有一些风。
But I remember, I can't remember if we got the offer or it might have been a Friday, we maybe had to wait till a Monday.
但我记得，我不记得我们是否收到了offer，或者可能是周五，我们可能不得不等到周一。
I can't remember.
我不记得了。
I think it was, I don't think it was immediate but I got the job like within days.
我认为是的，我不认为这是立竿见影的，但我几天之内就得到了这份工作。
Um, and then next year, you know, we're making a podcast about this.
嗯，明年，你知道，我们将制作一个关于此的播客。
Do you guys know the West Memphis three, the, the, the three kids who were, um, railroaded into, they were on death row for killing this, um, I think girl, it was kind of a satanic panic thing.
你们知道西孟菲斯三人吗，这，这，三个孩子，嗯，被铁路关进死牢，因为杀死了这个，嗯，我想女孩，这是一种撒旦恐慌的事情。
Oh, yeah.
哦，是的。
And they were called the West Memphis three and they got put on death row as teenagers.
他们被称为西孟菲斯三人组，十几岁时就被关进死牢。
they were, they were totally innocent.
他们是，他们是完全无辜的。
It was like an absolute sham.
这绝对是一场骗局。
But I think they were on death row for about 20 years.
但我认为他们在死囚牢房里待了大约20年。
And there was this guy, Damian Eccles, who I ended up doing in the evening at Joe's pub with this kind of evening of written letters.
还有一个人，达米安·埃克尔斯（Damian Eccles），我晚上在乔的酒吧里和他一起写了这样的一封信。
And I met him backstage.
我在后台遇见了他。
And he'd been on death row for 20 years.
他在死囚牢房里已经呆了20年了。
And I introduced myself to him because I had just seen a documentary about them.
我向他介绍了自己，因为我刚刚看了一部关于他们的纪录片。
And, and, uh, he said, I, I hope it's okay to say this.
而且，呃，他说，我，我希望这样说可以。
I'm such a fan.
我就是这样的粉丝。
I watched so much how I met your mother when I was behind bars.
当我入狱时，我看了很多我是如何遇见你母亲的。
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
I've never heard that from him.
我从来没有听他说过这样的话。
And I said, can I ask you, like, what was it about the show?
我说，我能问你一下，这个节目是关于什么的吗？
I'm always so curious.
我总是那么好奇。
What was it about the show that you wanted to see?
您想看的节目是什么？
And he said, he said, it was fake enough that it took me away from where I was, but it was real enough that it promised a world that I was hoping I could rejoin one day.
他说，他说，它足够假，它让我离开了原来的地方，但它又足够真实，它承诺了一个我希望有一天能重新加入的世界。
Wow.
哇。
That's amazing.
太棒了。
And I just that always stayed with me that kind of like hyper real but real kind of quality and what that can do to people.
我只是一直伴随着我那种超真实但真实的品质以及它可以对人们做什么。
You can look at the show as diversion from your troubles or you can look at the show as a meta commentary on your real troubles in your real life, right?
你可以把这个节目看作是你摆脱烦恼的消遣，或者你可以把这个节目看作是对你现实生活中真正麻烦的元评论，对吗？
Like it's got this it's got this ability to meet people where they are that part of part of what we're doing Carter Craig and I keep talking about this mystery that we're trying to solve is like, why does how I met your mother, why is it lasted so long, why do new generations keep discovering it, and why does it seem to be medicine, like soul medicine for people in hard times?
就像它有这样的能力，它有能力与人们见面，这是我们正在做的事情的一部分，卡特·克雷格和我一直在谈论我们试图解决的这个谜团，就像是，为什么我是如何遇见你母亲的，为什么它持续了这么久，为什么新一代不断发现它，为什么它似乎是一种药物，就像人们在困难时期的灵魂药物一样？
But you know, that story about Damian is like, I think really illustrates something about that.
但你知道，关于达米安的故事就像，我认为确实说明了这一点。
That's one of my favorite reviews of the show, I've ever, or assessments of the show, I think I've ever heard.
这是我最喜欢的对该节目的评论之一，或者我想我听过的对该节目的评估。
That's beautiful, yeah.
那很漂亮，是的。
There is so much more to our talk with Carter and you'll be able to hear it soon in a bonus episode of the show.
我们与卡特的谈话还有很多内容，您很快就能在节目的奖励剧集中听到。
So look out for how Craig met Carter.
所以请留意克雷格是如何认识卡特的。
If you want to delve into that sorted history, it's not sorted, it's delightful.
如果你想深入研究那段排序的历史，它没有排序，这很令人愉快。
If you follow or subscribe to the show, all our bonus episodes will just show up in your feed.
如果您关注或订阅该节目，我们所有的奖励剧集都会显示在您的提要中。
So hit that subscribe button.
所以点击订阅按钮。
Also, starting next week, we will begin our official rewatch of each episode of how I made my mother starting with the pilot.
另外，从下周开始，我们将从试播集开始正式重播我如何让我母亲的每一集。
We strongly suggest that you watch the episode before listening to our discussion.
我们强烈建议您在听我们的讨论之前先观看该集。
We know that most of you will have seen it once or twice or according to the amazing messages you have sent us 17 or 30 times, but it's time to start again.
我们知道你们大多数人都看过一两次，或者根据你们向我们发送了 17 或 30 次的令人惊叹的信息，但现在是重新开始的时候了。
So rewatch with us and if it's your first time watching, welcome.
因此，请与我们一起重新观看，如果这是您第一次观看，欢迎。
We're so happy you're here.
我们很高兴你在这里。
The very first day that we announced this podcast, we received questions and stories from around the world and we're looking forward to all of you sending yours in as well.
我们宣布这个播客的第一天，我们收到了来自世界各地的问题和故事，我们期待你们所有人也发送您的问题和故事。
Just go to the website how we made your mother dot com and click on contact.
只需访问我们如何创建您的母亲.com 的网站，然后单击“联系”即可。
And here are just a few of those incredible questions and stories we received from around the world.
以下只是我们从世界各地收到的一些令人难以置信的问题和故事。
This one is from Kajal in India.
这是来自印度卡加尔的。
Hello legendary people assuming I'm the first one to write.
各位传奇人物大家好，假设我是第一个写这篇文章的人。
Why would he assume that?
他为什么会这么认为？
I don't know.
我不知道。
is correct.
是正确的。
Very.
非常。
He was.
他是。
This was a person.
这是一个人。
Okay.
好的。
This is the first message.
这是第一条消息。
Good job.
好工作。
Forgive me.
对不起。
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
You were the callers.
你是打电话的人。
Shut it right.
关它吧。
Be assuming on the first one to write.
假设第一个写的。
And he was just wanted to wish the best of luck for this podcast.
他只是想祝这个播客好运。
Can't wait to hear what you guys have got to say.
迫不及待地想听听你们要说什么。
Thank you, Kajal.
谢谢你，卡加尔。
Wow.
哇。
Bad ass.
坏蛋。
Kajal.
卡贾尔。
Okay.
好的。
This one's from Michael and I ran.
这是迈克尔发来的，我跑了。
He says, every time the gang laughs or cries or in any matter emotional, I have these feelings too.
他说，每当这帮人笑或哭或任何情绪化的事情时，我也有这些感觉。
This one's from Mia in Germany.
这是来自德国米娅的。
First, thank you so much for this podcast.
首先，非常感谢您收听这个播客。
I'm rewatching the show every time I finish it.
每次看完这部剧我都会重温一遍。
My first tattoo is going to be an honor of him.
我的第一个纹身将是他的荣耀。
There's no way to get this data, but I'm really curious how many how I made my other tattoos are in there.
没有办法获得这些数据，但我真的很好奇我制作的其他纹身有多少。
I mean, I feel like I've seen literally dozens in person.
我的意思是，我觉得我亲眼见过几十个人。
I've seen upwards, yeah, of a hundred.
我见过的，是的，有一百个以上。
I mean, it's incredible.
我的意思是，这太不可思议了。
So thank you for staying in your bodies with memories That's commitment.
所以，谢谢你带着回忆留在你的身体里，这就是承诺。
I'm not sure I like the show that much.
我不确定我有多喜欢这个节目。
Here we go.
开始了。
This one's from Daniel.
这是丹尼尔发来的。
He's from Peru.
他来自秘鲁。
He says, him, he's my comfort series.
他说，他，他是我的安慰系列。
I watch it when I'm happy, when I am sad, when I'm mad.
我开心的时候看，悲伤的时候看，生气的时候看。
I want to thank you Craig and Carter.
我要感谢克雷格和卡特。
I'm adding that for creating this piece of art and you, Josh, for giving your heart and soul to this project.
我添加这一点是为了创造这件艺术品，而你，乔什，为这个项目付出了你的心和灵魂。
I own a little music box that plays love love Beyond Rose and own a ducky tie.
我有一个小音乐盒，可以播放《Beyond Rose》中的爱情，还有一条小领带。
This one's from Julia in Austria.
这是来自奥地利的朱莉娅。
The show helped me through some of the harder times, especially my quarter life crisis, when seemingly all of my friends have been in relationships and I was still on my own trying to figure out life.
这个节目帮助我度过了一些困难时期，尤其是我的四分之一人生危机，当时我所有的朋友似乎都已经恋爱了，而我仍然独自试图弄清楚生活。
From Danella, from Chile, she wrote to us in Spanish, and we got it Google translated, which led to this.
来自智利的达内拉（Danella）用西班牙语给我们写信，我们得到了谷歌翻译，这导致了这一点。
I started watching this series about two or three years ago.
我大约两三年前开始看这个系列。
My husband recommended it to me and I became obsessed with each of the episodes, the story, how the stories were woven in time, the flashbacks of the seasons, the pineapple, the pumpkin, et cetera.
我丈夫向我推荐了它，我开始沉迷于每一集、故事、故事如何及时编织、季节的闪回、菠萝、南瓜等等。
My obsession has been so great that my husband and I agreed that we would only watch it once a year.
我的痴迷是如此之大，以至于我和丈夫同意我们每年只看一次。
That's better English than I have speak in, so good job.
这英语比我说的好，干得好。
We've only watched the entire series once a year.
我们每年只看过整个系列一次。
Is that right?
是这样吗？
Interesting.
有趣的。
Well, I wonder how many times she's up to them.
好吧，我想知道她有多少次是这样的。
What does that equal?
那等于什么？
And how long it takes to watch the entire series?
看完整个系列需要多长时间？
Right.
正确的。
Watched one a day, it would be two thirds of a year.
一天看一次，一年就占了三分之二。
That's a good point.
这是一个很好的观点。
She's not minimizing it that much if she's watching it at that rate, okay.
如果她以这样的速度观看，她就不会那么最小化，好吧。
But I love it.
但我喜欢它。
This one is from Amanda in New York City.
这是来自纽约市的阿曼达。
There are no words to describe with the show how I met your mother means to me.
无法用言语来形容这部剧对我来说意味着什么。
But I will try.
但我会尝试。
I was 19 when I watched the show for the first time, which was only seven months ago, showed to me by my friend Samantha, who claimed I'd love it.
我第一次观看这个节目时才 19 岁，那是在七个月前，我的朋友萨曼莎向我展示了这个节目，她声称我会喜欢它。
I didn't believe her at first, but that night, we watched half of season one, and I was hooked.
一开始我并不相信她，但那天晚上，我们看了第一季的一半，我就被迷住了。
I think how I met your mother taught me it was okay to take time to get where you need to be.
我想我与你母亲的相遇告诉我，花时间去到达你需要去的地方是可以的。
Finding comedy in serious situations, especially the way the show executed it, is a metaphor that I've used in my real life.
在严肃的情况下寻找喜剧，尤其是节目的执行方式，是我在现实生活中使用的一个比喻。
You need to find the humor, enjoy, and even the most dire situations.
你需要找到幽默、享受，甚至是最可怕的情况。
That really is the only way you can truly get past them.
这确实是你真正能够克服它们的唯一方法。
I can say with my full chest that this show saved me from a really hard time in my life and taught me it was okay and to never give up because in the end you'll end up where you need to be and most importantly you'll be happy with it.
我可以满怀信心地说，这部剧把我从人生中最艰难的时刻救了出来，并教会我一切都好，永远不要放弃，因为最终你会到达你需要的地方，最重要的是你会对此感到满意。
This show is the definition of trust, the process, and I adore it very much.
这个节目是信任、过程的定义，我非常喜欢它。
Carter and Craig, thank you for this show and Josh, thanks for executing the most imperfect role in the most perfect way.
卡特和克雷格，感谢你们的表演，乔什，感谢你们以最完美的方式演绎了最不完美的角色。
I love that.
我喜欢那个。
That's a great compliment.
这是一个很好的赞美。
Yeah.
是的。
Ted Mosby is far from perfect, but he's better because he's human.
特德·莫斯比远非完美，但他更好，因为他是人。
You did a great job portraying that.
你在描绘这一点上做得很好。
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
谢谢，谢谢，谢谢。
Wow, that's beautiful.
哇，太漂亮了。
Thank you, Amanda.
谢谢你，阿曼达。
Unbelievable.
难以置信。
Thank you, Amanda.
谢谢你，阿曼达。
Thank you to all of you.
谢谢大家。
I just love that the framing of that was like flashback to when I was 19.
我只是喜欢这个框架，就像我 19 岁时的回忆一样。
By the way, I'm still 19.
顺便说一句，我还19岁。
I enjoyed the framing of that very much.
我非常喜欢这个框架。
I remember when I was 19, seven months ago.
我记得七个月前，我19岁。
I'm still 19.
我还19岁。
Okay.
好的。
I loved it.
我喜欢它。
Amanda, amazing message.
阿曼达，令人惊奇的消息。
Thank you for that.
谢谢你。
Yeah.
是的。
Fantastic.
极好的。
Craig, what's it like for you when you hear all this?
克雷格，当你听到这一切时，你有什么感觉？
us.
我们。
It's mind blowing.
真是令人兴奋。
It's absolutely mind blowing knowing that it helps people get through a hard time and you know, gave them some sort of framing device for their own life in a way.
知道它可以帮助人们度过困难时期，并且在某种程度上为他们自己的生活提供了某种框架装置，这绝对令人兴奋。
It's very humbling because we started off here.
这是非常谦卑的，因为我们从这里开始。
We are at the beginning of talking about this series.
我们正处于谈论这个系列的开始。
We never could have imagined it with the two messages like that.
我们从来没有想象过会有这样的两条消息。
It's just it's deeply humbling and we don't take it lightly.
只是这令人深感谦卑，我们不会掉以轻心。
Thank you best.
最好谢谢你。
And you know, I think that at your best, at your wildest, At the wildest edges of your imagining of what the show could be, it's that, right?
你知道，我认为在你最好的时候，在你最疯狂的时候，在你对演出的想象的最疯狂的边缘，就是这样，对吗？
No, you make art with the hope.
不，你带着希望来创作艺术。
I hope it has, it's like a message in a bottle.
我希望它有，就像瓶子里的信息。
Like I hope this reaches someone and I hope the message is not eroded and destroyed by the time it gets there.
就像我希望这句话能够传达给某人一样，我希望这条信息在到达那里时不会被侵蚀和破坏。
There's something so great about, you show something and they have the response and beyond even your response, the response of what you would hope.
这是一件很棒的事情，你展示了一些东西，他们得到了回应，甚至超出了你的回应，得到了你所希望的回应。
I just find it incredibly moving when art is received in such an open-hearted sincere, beautiful way.
当艺术以如此开放、真诚、美丽的方式被接受时，我感到非常感动。
It must be really, I mean, we share in it, but you really, you and Carter and your team pend the thing.
我的意思是，我们必须共同参与，但你、你和卡特以及你的团队确实在等待这件事。
So I just think, I hope other people who are listening to how I met your mother, even other people, sorry, who worked on how I met your mother, the props department and the editors and I'm sure people who worked on the show are tuning into this.
所以我只是想，我希望其他正在听我如何遇见你母亲的人，甚至是其他人，对不起，那些参与《我如何遇见你母亲》的人、道具部门和编辑，我相信参与该节目的人们正在关注这一点。
I hope they also feel some sense of, wasn't it incredible to be a part of something that's special?
我希望他们也能感受到，成为特殊事物的一部分不是很不可思议吗？
Yeah, everybody put their heart and soul into it and it got a lot of the people who worked on it.
是的，每个人都全身心地投入其中，并且得到了很多人的参与。
Josh and I included making the show helped us get through some of our hardest times.
乔什和我制作这个节目帮助我们度过了最困难的时期。
I find it and I find that it just seems like some of that energy made it into the show.
我找到了它，我发现似乎有一些能量融入到了这部剧中。
The show was that to us in creating it in real time and now people years and years later people who are 19 years old and trying going through their own hard time are feeling that in the show and it just makes me feel like we baked we baked something in there.
这个节目对我们来说是实时创作的，现在很多年过去了，那些19岁的人正在努力度过自己的艰难时期，他们在节目中感受到了这一点，这让我觉得我们在里面烘烤了一些东西。
That's lasting.
那是持久的。
And also this notion of watching characters go through hard times with this sense of of chosen family and community and that they landed on their feet and they were able to laugh in the midst of hard times.
还有这种观看角色经历困难时期的观念，带着这种选择家庭和社区的感觉，他们站起来，能够在困难时期欢笑。
Like how am I my mother was still, it was brightly lit, It was trot on a soundstage.
就像我妈妈一动不动，灯火通明，在摄影棚里小跑一样。
There's laughter piped in.
里面传来笑声。
It was it was a fantasy, but it also was attempting to gesture at something very true about being alive.
这是一个幻想，但它也试图表达关于活着的一些非常真实的事情。
How we made your mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas.
《我们如何造就你的母亲》由乔什·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯主持并担任监制。
The show is produced by me, Alec Lev, and our co-producer is Doug Matica.
该节目由我 Alec Lev 制作，我们的联合制作人是 Doug Matica。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves at Point of Blue Studios, artwork by John Marrow.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是 Point of Blue Studios 的 Alex Reeves，作品由 John Marrow 设计。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在 Apple 播客或您选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论该节目。
It really does help the show.
对节目确实有帮助。
Our theme song is NYC by our own Josh Radner, special thanks to Lowly Kennedy and Elliott Connards.
我们的主题曲是我们自己的 Josh Radner 创作的 NYC，特别感谢 Lowly Kennedy 和 Elliott Connards。
Visit howwemadeyourmother.com to sign up for our sub-stack mailing list and for links to our social media.
请访问 howwemadeyourmother.com 注册我们的子堆栈邮件列表以及我们社交媒体的链接。
You can also click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
您还可以单击联系页面向我们发送电子邮件或语音消息。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
您的故事和问题是节目的重要组成部分。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's newsletters on Substack, read Craig Thomas' published prose at CraigThomasRider.com and you can subscribe to my Dead Father Society also on Substack.
在 Substack 上订阅 Josh Radner 的时事通讯，阅读 Craig Thomas 在 CraigThomasRider.com 上发表的散文，您也可以在 Substack 上订阅我的《已故父亲协会》。
To learn about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise money for congenital heart disease research, check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
要了解您如何做出改变，这显示了正在进行的为先天性心脏病研究筹集资金的活动，请查看我们网站顶部的“做出改变”选项卡。
This episode was made possible by the support of Backyard Ventures, marketing provided by Tink Media.
这一集在 Backyard Ventures 的支持下得以实现，营销由 Tink Media 提供。
People will, in fact, dance.
事实上，人们会跳舞。
I remember in season one, we would have to drive somewhere else to sound mix the show.
我记得在第一季中，我们必须开车去其他地方为节目混音。
And the guard letting me on was like, how am I a trim other?
让我上车的警卫说，我怎么是个整洁的人呢？
That's that reality dating show, right?
这就是那个真人秀相亲节目吧？
Yeah.
是的。
And I think I was like, yes it is.
我想我当时想，是的。
Well, the first reaction was always, sorry, what about my money?
嗯，第一反应总是，​​抱歉，我的钱呢？
What did you say?
你说什么？
I've realized lately that the products I use every single morning genuinely affect how I feel for the rest of the day.
最近我意识到我每天早上使用的产品确实会影响我一天中剩下的时间的感觉。
If something feels heavy, greasy, overly makeupy or complicated, I just stop reaching for it.
如果某样东西感觉很重、油腻、化妆过度或复杂，我就会停止接触它。
That's why I've been loving primarily pierce new sun serum tinted SPF.
这就是为什么我一直最喜欢 pierce new 防晒精华有色 SPF。
It gives mineral SPF 30 protection and enough coverage to make my skin look even and healthy, but it still looks like my skin.
它提供 SPF 30 的矿物质保护和足够的遮盖力，使我的皮肤看起来均匀健康，但它看起来仍然像我的皮肤。
It has this really fresh, lived and glow and their lip and cheek tint has become one of those products I keep throwing on throughout the day because it makes me look instantly more awake and put together in like 10 seconds.
它真的很新鲜、充满活力、容光焕发，它们的唇部和脸颊色调已经成为我整天不断使用的产品之一，因为它让我看起来立刻更加清醒，并且在 10 秒钟内就完成了。
The whole vibe just feels very effortless.
整个氛围感觉非常轻松。
Skin first, clean girl beauty, products that enhance your skin.
肌肤第一，干净少女美，提升肌肤品质的产品。
If you've been wanting your routine to feel lighter, simpler, and more natural this summer, definitely check out Primely Peer's Sun Serum and Lip and Cheek Tints.
如果您希望今年夏天的日常护理变得更轻松、更简单、更自然，一定要看看 Primely Peer 的防晒精华和唇颊彩。